l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 nous abordons la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Charles de courourson pour le groupe
Libert indépendant autremè et territoire
pour une durée de 15
minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues le gouvernement nous
présente son projet loi de finances pour
2024 comme un moyen de consolider nos
finances publiques tout en continuant de
baisser la fiscalité et d'investir pour
l'avenir il s'agit hélas que de vœux
pieux bien loin de la réalité les
éléments qui é on porter à notre
connaissance décrivent au contraire une
situation compliquée et dangereuse vous
me répondrez monsieur ministre que le
contexte économique international est
difficile et qu'il est plus facile à une
opposition d'être mécontente qu'à un
gouvernement de mettre en œuvre des
réformes
structurelle la première ministre
montrera tout à l'heure à la tribune
dans quelques minutes ou dans quelques
heures pour mettre fin à ce débat en
prétendant être responsable quel étrange
discussion générale en attendant que
vous renouveliez ce dénis de démocratie
et le vote à coup 493 j'aimis revenir
sur trois
points la première
euh la la première raison euh de notre
opposition c'est que vous ne tenez pas
les dépenses des dépenses continuent
d'augmenter le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques prévoit une hausse de dépenses
primaires nettes de 2,6 %. et non pas du
tout une baisse comme vous l'annoncez ce
pdf acte ainsi la montée en charge des
des budgets régaliens portés par les
différents lois de programmation
thématique 3 milliards 3 pour la défense
500 millions pour la mission
euh écologie euh 7 milliards pour la
mission écologie pardon 500 millions
pour l'intérieur et 500 millions pour la
justice parmi les 580 milliards d'euros
de dépenses de l'État les dépenses
d'investissement mes chers collègues ne
représente plus que 29 milliards en 2024
soit seulement 6 % du budget général
dont la moitié au titre de la défense
une fois de plus les Françaises et les
Français vont donc s'endetter uniquement
pour gérer les affaires courantes
monsieur les ministre le ratio entre
dépenses courantes et dépenses
d'investissement n'est pas bon cela cela
be être écrit dans votre dossier de
presse ce budget n'est pas un budget
d'avenir la deuxième raison se trouve du
côté des recettes d'une part les
hypothèses macro-économiques sur
lesquelles vous fondez vos prévision so
optimistes de la Ve même du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques prévoyez une
croissance en volume de 14 c'était 16
avant ce n'est pas raisonnable vous
auriez dû vous fonder sur des
estimations plus modestes à 0,8 ou 1 %
comme la majorité des analystes de même
manière vos hypothèses d'inflation sont
très favorables et ne tiennent pas
compte de la hausse récente des prix du
pétrole d'autre part vous vous félicitez
d'avoir baissé les recettes fiscales de
50 milliards durant le précédent
quinquena pourtant messieur les ministre
vous n'avez pas réduit la pression
fiscale le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire est prévu est quasiment
stable depuis 2016 puisqu'il est prévu à
44,4 % du PIB en 2024 il était de 44,6 %
fin 2016 vous n'avez fait en réalité que
freiner la hausse tendantielle des
recettes la part des impositions en
France est l'une des plus élevées au
monde mais ce qu' l'on ne dit pas c'est
que la charge fiscale est mal réparti
notre modèle fiscal est plus adapté au
nouveau secteur de l'économie ne tient
pas suffisamment compte du niveau de
fortune et que faites-vous en 2024
certes vous réduisez la CVAE d'un
milliard mais vous créez également une
taxe probablement antionstitutionnel sur
les infrastructures de transport qui
devrait rapporter 600 millions d'euros
cela ne pourra qu'entraîner une
augmentation des tarifs des péage et des
billets d'avion pour les usagers c'est
bien une hausse d'impôt le groupe le
propose des mesures de justice fiscale
revoir le barê de l'impôt sur le revenu
et la fiscalité du patrimoine financier
afin de faire contribuer les ménages les
plus aisés à laass nationale nous
soutenons une extension de l'assiette de
la taxe sur les transactions financières
afin de lutter contre la spéculation et
le capitalisme financiarisé nous
proposons une hausse du taux de la taxe
sur les gafas la suspension de la baisse
de la CVE ou encore le prolongement de
la contribution sur la rende infra
marginal de la production d'électricité
nous avons enfin déposé des amendements
pour refondre la fiscalité des rachats
d'action certaines de nos propositions
ont été adopté en commission des
finances et nous en réjouissons ces
augmentations de recettes ne baeront pas
sur la classe moyenne ou les salair
arier notre vote sur le PLF dépendra
d'ailleurs pour partie de la capacité du
gouvernement à conserver toute ou partie
de ses proposition après 493
troisièmement vous tentez de maquiller
le solde public par tous les moyens en
2024 le gouvernement prévoit un déficite
de l'état de 145 milliards d'euros
certes il s'agit d'une amélioration
puisque ce déficit diminuit de 20
milliards par rapport à 2023 mais le sol
structurel lui ne s'améliore que de 04
points de PIB soit de 10 milliards ce
qui est plus gr
c'est que près de 14 milliards sur les
16 milliards d'économies que vous
annoncez sont des économies de
constatation lié à l'extinction de
dispositifs temporaires vous ne vous
livrez pas un réel effort structurel de
maîtrise de la dépense en revanche votre
effort pour bâtir un solde budgétaire de
l'État en trompeeleœil et de notoriété
publique
vous
vous vous navez pas une véritable
stratégie votre stratégie c'est la
stratégie dit du sapeur camamber vous
faites des trous pour emboucher
ailleurs vous entendez en effet réaliser
cette année un double holdup d'abord sol
largic Arco le plfsf Pr une ponction de
1 milliard en 2024 ensuite vous rêvez de
prélever à lunedic 2 milliards en 2023
et 2 mliard 5 en 2024 dans le premier
cas de la jicarco vous pénalisez des
partenaires sociaux qui ont eu une bonne
gestion et dans le second vous réduisez
les excédents de l'unéque qui en a
pourtant bien besoin pour réduire sa
dette considérable de plus de 50
milliards le pire étant que toutes ces
opérations sont neutre du point de vue
du solde public au sens de Maastrich
puisque ces deux organismes
appartiennent aux administrations
publiques et comme si cela ne suffisit
pas vous vous en prenez également aux
Chambres de Commerce et d'Industrie aux
Chambres de Métiers et d'artisanat et
aux Chambres d'agriculture vous demandez
à ces corps intermédiaires de licencier
toujours plus d'argent d'agent alors que
vous augmentez vous le nombre de TP pour
l'État et ses opérateurs face
à la la la à cette cette levée de
bouclier le ministre de l'Économie vient
d'annoncer tout à l'heure qu'il y
renonçait je l'en félicite mais il a
fallu toute la pression de tous ceux qui
se sont élevés contre cela et les votes
de la commission des finances en fin de
compte vous levererez 285 milliards
d'euros de dette en 2024 et vous
rembourserez 155 milliards ainsi vous
Perez plus de 50 milliards EUR d'intérêt
soit un/art des recettes de TVA en 2027
les intérêts de la dette de l'État
taidront 71 milliards d'après le pable
gouvernemental mais d'après le Conseil
des finances publiques on en sera à 84
milliards à ces remarques libitaires
s'ajoute un problème majeur votre budget
ne répond pas aux principales
préoccupations du pays à savoir le
logement et le pouvoir d'achat d'abord
votre projet doitêtre finance et
quasiment vide de tout contenu en
matière de logement la crise du logement
a de multiples facteurs les mutations
sociales les mouvements de population le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt bien sûr
par la Banque centrale européenne qui
freine l'accès au crédit des
particuliers et des opérateurs ainsi que
la hausse du coût des matières premières
mais aussi le poids des normes dans la
construction qui est estimé à l'ordre de
20 % sur les de à tro dernières années
et puis la réflexion du foncier qui est
notamment la conséquence de la
planification du pays tout cela pèse sur
le secteur de la construction qui est
pourtant l'un des moteurs de la
croissance et de l'emploi en revanche
vous proposez un second plan logement
d'abord qu'il faut saluer sur le
principe néanmoins il ne suffit pas
d'inscrire le droit au logement dans la
loi pour qu'il soit effectif pour que la
politique de lutte contre la grande
pauvreté soit efficace il faudrait
augmenter la mobilité dans le parc
locatif social et privé pour rappel la
Cour des comptes estimait en 2017 que la
hausse d'un point de mob ité dans le
parc social réduirait le besoin de
construction de près de 47000 places et
pour cela il faudrait que les ménages
modestes puissent continuer à accéder à
la propriété mais que proposez-vous dans
ce PLF une mesure anachronique et
dangereuse vous réduisez le prês à taux
zéro ce qui freine l'accession à la
propriété et vous bloquez le parcours
résidentiel ensuite vous ne fondez pas
suffisamment le pouvoir d'achat des
foyers précaires et des travailleurs
modestes les députés Liot demandent un
chèque carburant pour les salariés qui
utilisent leur voiture pour se rendre à
leur travail et qui tiennent compte de
la distance entre le domicide et le lieu
de travail ainsi qu'un chèque
alimentaire pour les personnes sous le
seuil de pauvreté et de poursuivre la
hausse des crédit pour l'ensemble des
associations qui s'occupent de la lutte
contre la pauvreté pour les étudiants le
groupe duot défend le repas 1 € euh et
dans les restaurants universitaires
ainsi qu'une Haus substantielle des
bourses sur sociaux s'agissant de
concitoyens ultramarins la suspension du
paiement des redevances eau à magnotte
doit être étendue à l'archipel
guadeloupéenne et être prolongé aussi
longtemps que la crise de l'eau durera
ensuite le bouclier qualité-prix doit
être renforcé notamment en retirant la
TVA sur les biens concernés ce qui
évitera que les marges de la
distribution augmentent enfin à
Saint-Pierre et miklon l'État doit tenir
ses engagements de financement du port
et non reporter cette charge sur la
collectivité concant ant les crédits en
faveur de l'écologie vous revendiquez
une hausse de 1 Millard 6 d'euros
consacré à ma prime Renov en 2024 il
manque pourtant encore 700 millions
d'euros dans ce PLF pour faire face à
cette à la demande il faut davantage
soutenir monsieur le ministre les
rénovations globales certes mais la
puisance publique doit d'abord financer
les travaux des ménages les plus
modestes est-il raisonnable de penser
que la classe moyenne va pouvoir avancer
des aides pour des des rénovations
structurantes qui sont extrêmement
coûteuses vous refusez enfin de financer
ces dépenses d'avenir par un prélèvement
temporaire sur le patrimoine financier
des ménages les plus aisés pourtant
proposés par Jean pisaniferie et Selma
mafous s'agissant des finances locales
vous communiquez sur hausse de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement de
220 millions mais monsieur le ministre
c'est 220 millions c'est 08 %
d'augmentation c'est totalement
insuffisant au regard d'une prévision
base d'inflation qui est votre prévision
à 2,6 %. cela signifie que vous
augmentez la DGF en valeur très
légèrement mais que vous la baissez en
Auron constant de l'ordre de presque 2 %
dans vos prévisions et probablement un
peu plus vu la sousévaluation du taux
d'inflation de même vous ne compensez
pas l'augmentation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaire survêtu en juin dernier
mon groupe porte une série d'amendements
pour éviter toute baisse réelle des
recettes de fonctionnement des
collectivités et les départements ruraux
sont dans une situation difficile les
dépenses sociales continuent d'augmenter
pour ce qui concerne donc une bonne
partie des départements y compris des
départements très urbains tandis que
l'État ne compense pas justement leurs
charges et que leurs recettes fiscal
essentiellement les DMTO chutent vous
les estimez à une chute de 16 % mais la
chute est extrêmement variable selon le
département à tel point que plus de 10
départ appartement sont en déficit de
fonctionnement et monsieur le rapporteur
général nous dit toujours oh il y a pas
de problème des collectivités
territorial regardeer le montant des
dépenses de des des des accumulations
global oui mais la globalité ne veut
rien dire monsieur le rapporteur général
la réalité c'est chacun d'entre eux et
et et vous-même vous en êtes à essayer
de créer un fond pour éviter
l'effondrement déjà de 10 départements
c'est 10 départements aujourd'hui mais
ça sera 15 à 20 demain puis 25 puis 30
ouis et donc c'est un vrai problème qui
n'est pas résolu alors sagissant des
finances sociales je voudrais rappeler
le coup net de la réforme des retraites
qui est un déficit de 200 millions
d'euros en 2024 d'après le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques et encore cela ne
tient pas compte des effets de bord de
la réforme sur l'assurance chômage le
RSA et la branche maladie c'est quelque
chose qui est souligné par le Haut
conseil que
ministre ne veulent surtout pas évoquer
oui le la réforme des retraites c'est un
coûte de 200 millions en 2024 c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques et en fait c'est plus
de 200 millions puisque il y a l'effet
indirect voilà oui mais on en parle pas
trop hein et le sold des régimes
obligatoires de sécurité sociale est en
déficit de 8 milillards 8 tandis que
londam croit plus vite que la croissance
et que l'hôpital manque toujours de près
de 2 milliards d'euros de finance
face un gouvernement qui veut baisser
les impôts alors qu'il n'en a pas les
moyens qui ne propose aucune économie
structurelle significative et qui prév
saisir l'argent des administrations de
sécurité social plutôt que de
rationaliser son propre budget le groupe
Viot votera en l'état de ce texte contre
le projet de loi de
finance je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Louis
Marguerite pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance madame la Présidente mais
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général de la
commission mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues le projet de loi
de finance pour 2024 n'est pas un budget
de rigueur c'est pas un budget
d'austérité mais c'est un budget de
responsabilité et d'ambition vis-à-vis
de nos finances publiques vis-à-vis des
Français et visà vous allez voir et
vis-à-vis de la transition écologique
car oui le projet de loi de finance pour
2024 est un budget de responsabilité
tout d'abord de responsabilité vis-à-vis
de nos finances publiques il consacre en
effet 16 milliards d'euros d'économie
budgétaire soit 6 milliards de plus que
ce ce qui était initialement prévu car
oui notre objectif est clair et assumé
c'est celui de réduire notre déficit
public à 2,7 % du produit intérieur brut
d'ici
2027 conformément à la trajectoire
pluréannuelle de redressement de nos
finances publiques c'est une question de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Françaises
et des Français et de crédibilité
vis-à-vis de ceux qui nous financent
tous les jours pour financer notre
modèle social grâce à l'adoption de ce
projet de loi de finance nous l'espérons
nous parviendrons à tenir notre objectif
de déficit de 4,4 % de déficit publ en
2024 mes chers collègues depuis 3 ans
nous avons su faire face à une
succession de crise de crise majeure en
pleine tempête qu'il s'agisse du covid
de l'impact de la guerre en Ukraine de
la crise inflationniste l'économie
française a démontré sa solidité et si
nous avons résisté c'est parce que
l'État et la puissance publi dans son
ensemble a mis en œuvre tous les moyens
nécessaires pour protéger les Français
quoi qu'il en coûte mais l'heure est
désormais au rétablissement de nos
comptes publics quoi qu'il arrive parce
que cet objectif c'est celui que ce
projet de loi de finance porte oui ce ce
projet de loi de finance est un budget
de
responsabilité de responsabilité
vis-à-vis des Français ensuite
parce que c'est ce budget renforce
considérablement les moyens de la
justice les moyens de la défense les
moyens de la sécurité de l'éducation
nationale du pouvoir d'achat et cela
répond ainsi aux attentes et aux
préoccupations légitimes de nos
compatriotes quel qu'ils soi ou où
qu'ils se trouvent et quel que soient
leurs opinions politiques ce budget est
enfin un budget de responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la transition écologique
comme l'a souligné tout à l'heure le
ministre
nav parce que oui réussir la transition
énergétique et écologique est une
priorité absolue une priorité absolue
parce que ce projet de loi de finance
augmente de 21 % les crédits accordés à
la transition écologique par rapport à
l'année dernière en passant de 33 à 40
milliards d'euros mes chers collègues 33
à 40 40 milliards d'euros ce n'était
jamais arrivé par le
passé une priorités oui historique une
priorité absolu parce que 4,6 milliards
d'euros sont affectés à nos réseaux de
transport dont 3,9 milliards d'euros
pour le financement direct de la
planification écologique de l'entretien
et de la construction de nouvell l de
nouvelles lignes ferroviaire ou
fluviales et du financement des
transports collectifs cela représente
une progression de 20 % par rapport à
l'année
2023 une priorité absolue parce qu'avec
ce budget 2024 nous consacrons 5
milliards d'euros à la R énergétique du
logement des Français et 300 millions
d'euros à la rénovation des bâtiments du
parc immobilier de l'État voter ce
budget c'est soutenir un investissement
sans précédent à même de relever
ensemble le défi de notre temps du 21e
siècle celui du climat voter ce budget
2024 c'est soutenir la réduction
progressive des niches fiscales brunes
qui sont néfastes au climat voter ce
budget 2024 c'est soutenir la fin
progressive de ces niches qui sont
néfastes pour l'environnement et la
santé humaine et contraire à nos
objectifs de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre c'est notamment supprimer dès
le 1er janvier 2024 les tarifs réduits
d'accise sur les produits
pétroliers ce budget mes chers collègues
nous pouvons en être fiers parce que
malgré les crise malgré l'inflation qui
frappe no nos concitoyens il répond aux
attentes des Français fier parce que
tous les budgets principaux de l'État
sont en augmentation par rapport à
l'année dernière fier parce que notre
ambition est sérieuse désendetter le
pays tout en assurant la souveraineté de
demain mes chers collègues le projet de
loi de finances 2024 porte une autre
ambition celle de garantir notre
souveraineté garantir notre souveraineté
c'est d'abord augmenter les moyens de
nos services publics régaliens afin de
répondre aux défis auquels nous vons
nous devons tous faire face d'abord la
guerre en Ukraine qui nécessite
d'ajuster notre budget conformément au
programme d'investissement massif que
nous avons adopté dans cette dans cet
hémicycle au cours de la loi la loi de
programmation militaire ensuite garantir
notre souveraineté c'est répondre au
défis sécuritaires qui implique de
renforcer les moyens à destination de
nos forces de l'ordre et à destination
de la justice pour y parvenir ce budget
augmente de 3,3 milliards d'euros les
crédits consacrés à nos armées afin
d'accélérer le renouvellement des
capacités opérationnelles conformément à
la loi de programmation militaire pour
renforcer les moyens accordés à nos
politiques régaliennes ce budget
augmente de 5 100 millions d'euros 500
millions d'euros de plus par an les
moyens accordés à notre justice pour
porter son budget à plus de 10 milliards
d'euros en 2024 ce n'était jamais arrivé
par le
passé enfin augmenter le budget alloué à
notre justice et rendre possible le
financement du recrutement de 10000
équivalent temps plein 10000 agents peu
plus sans doute supplémentaires sur 4
ans et la construction de nouvelles
places de prison mes chers collègu
l'éducation et laamenien de notre
jeunesse sont également une priorité
absolue c'est pourquoi ce budget de
projet de finance 2024 octroie les
moyens nécessaires pour porter notre
ambition d'excellence pour nos élèves il
permet d'offrir plus de liberté
pédagogique et plus de reconnaissance à
nos professeurs ce budget fixe également
un cap clair sur la formation et
l'accompagnement vers l'enseignement
supérieur et vers l'emploi afin de
réunir cet objectif 2,8 milliards
d'euros sont mobilisés pour financer la
revalorisation historique de la
rémunération des enseignants là aussi ce
n'était pas arrivé oui beaucoup de
choses sont historiques et de plus 468
millions d'euros près de 500 millions
d'euros viendront financer en 2024 la
rémunération des lycées des lycéens
professionnels qui sont en période de
formation en milieu professionnel et
enfin nous allons dans ce projet BL de
finance 3,9 milliards d'euros pour les
aides à l'embauche afin de soutenir
notre soutien massif à l'apprentissage
et atteindre l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixé 1 million d'apprentis
annuels d'ici la fin du quinquena mes
chers collègues garantir notre notre
souveraineté se fait également en
soutenant notre croissance économique ce
budget porte une autre ambition celle de
réformer et d'accompagner nos acteurs
économiques pour répondre aux évolutions
du marché en accélérant la
transformation des secteurs clés de
l'économie la facilitation de
l'innovation et le déploiement d'une
partie de l'économie dans vers des
domaines stratégiques pour y parvenir ce
budget consacle 7,7 milliards d'euros au
plan France 2030 afin d'accompagner nos
entreprises et de soutenir des
programmes très in est très populaire
comme le programme frenchtech 2030 de
plus ce ce budget investit 500 millions
d'euros de plus pour la recherche
française c'est également avec ce projet
de BL de finance mes chers collègues un
budget de soutien massif aux
collectivités avec
54,8 milliards d'euros de concours
financiers de l'État à destination des
collectivités dont une dotation générale
de fonctionnement en hausse de 220
millions d'euros soit un total de 27
millions d'euros 77 milliards d'euros
pardon par rapport à l'année 2023 C qui
avait déjà vu une augmentation de son
montant ce qui n'était pas arrivé depuis
2010 très chers collègues 2010
aussi c'est bien de citer les bons
auteurs soutenir les collectivités c'est
également maintenir les dotations de
soutien l'investissement local à 2
milliards d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement et une dsil exceptionnelle
de 110 millions d'euros grâce au plan de
relance enfin nous consacrons dans ce
budget une augmentation de 250 millions
d'euros pour le fond de compensation de
la TVA vous le connaissez bien aux
dépenses d'aménagement mes chers
collègues ce ce Budet 2024 c'est aussi
celui du rayonnement de la France il
n'aura échappé à personne que nous
accueillerons dans quelques mois les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques pour la
première fois depuis
1924 dans cette perspective le budget
augmente de 228 millions d'euros les
moyens consacrés à notre audiovisuel
public et de 86 millions d'euros les
moyens àoués au patrimoine à la mémoire
et la construction d'établissements
culturels qui seront clés pour la
réussite de cet événement les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
accueilleront 15000 athlètes
plus de 40000 bénévoles 600000
spectateurs pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture 13,5 millions de spectateurs
et plus de 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde pour
faire de cet événement une réussite
notre budget accorde 100 millions
d'euros à la Société pour la livraison
des ouvrages olympiques 30 millions
d'euros pour le comité d'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques et
6 millions d'euros pour le programme
gagné en France qui a voocation à
renforcer les conditions offertes à nos
athlètes mes chers collègues les moyens
colossaux que nous avons agagé pour la
crise du covid en 2020 le démontre des
moyens qui n'existent nul part ailleurs
dans le monde notre priorité a toujours
été de protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et de lutter contre la vie
chère comme l'a souligné le rapporteur
du budget le rapporteur général du
budget Jean-René casenu les Français on
ont été les Européens les mieux protégés
en 2023 en 2024 l'inflation de devrait
poursuivre son refus en atignant 2,4 %
de prévision afin de protéger ce pouvoir
d'achat le budget 2024 consque 3,7
milliards d'euros pour la revalorisation
salariale dans la fonction publique qui
devrait atteindre en moyenne 4,5 % de
plus l'état investit 6 6,1 milliards
d'euros pour financer l'indexation du
barê de l'impôt sur le revenu de
l'inflation grâce à cette mesure très
attendue les Français dont le salaire à
moins augmenté que l'inflation verront
très concrètement leurs impôt sur le
revenu baissé c'est aussi pour protéger
le pouvoir d'achat des Français que ce
budget pré voit de consacrer 18,5
milliards d'euros 18,5 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour revaloriser les
prestations sociales donc 14 milliards
pour les retraites dont on a beaucoup
parlé très concrètement c'est 18
milliards d'euros cela représente 80 €
par mois supplémentaire par retraité
moyen 50 € par mois pour un retraité au
minimum vieillesse 28 € par mois par un
pour un bénéficiaire au RSA et 45 € ce
sont les chiffres monsieur 45 € par mois
pour un un bénéficiaire de la location
adulte handicapé maises chers collèguue
ce projet protégera plus efficacement
les plus les plus modestes et les plus
fragiles du pays en en consacrant à ce
budget la solidarité pour pour y
parvenir 68 millions d'euros pour la
pour la prime adapte en plus 39 millions
d'euros pour accompagner les personnes
en situation de de handicap en plus 50
millions d'euros pour le fond
territorial d'accessibilité et cetera et
cetera enfin enfin Mesdames et Messieurs
chers collègues le ministre Bruno Lemer
l'a annoncé ce jour le budget favorisera
encore et plus davantage le partage la
valeur lorsqu'une entreprise est en
capacité de racheter ses actions elle
sera obligée de rouvrir des accords
d'intéressement et la et de
participation et d'augmenter davantage
la rémunération de ses salariés nous
maintenons notre notre ambition celle de
mieux rémunérer le travail de réduire la
dépense public et de réduire la pression
fiscale qui pèse sur les ménages et qui
pèse sur les entreprises c'est
l'engagement que nous avons pris devant
les Français et nous nous y tiendrons
enfin ce budget sera un budget de lutte
contre la fraude sur la fraude fiscale
avec la création inédit d'un délit
d'incitation à la fraude fiscale
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues mesdames et et Messieurs des
députés de la majorité comme de
l'opposition votre responsabilité et
notre responsabilité est immense la
puissance française de demain dépend de
dépend de notre budget
d'aujourd'hui l'usage l'usage des
dispositions de l'article 493 de la
Constitution n'est pas une
fatalité il dépend il dépend de notre
capacité collective travailler
à poursuivre le dialogue et à dépasser
l'écvage mesdames et messieurs mesdames
et messieurs du groupe les républicains
du Parti socialiste mes chers collègues
du groupe écologiste et du groupe Lot
entre l'incompétence du rassemblement
national et le projet de faillite qui
est celui de la France insoumise il y a
une autre voie il y a une autre voie
celle de la responsabilité il y a une
autre voie celle de la responsabilité et
celle de l'avenir de nos enfants il faut
il faut un Budet à la France mes chers
collègues il faut un budget à la France
nous le
devons vous aurez l'occasion de la
parole est à Monsieur Marguerite s'il
vous plaît m chers fa un budget à la
France mes chers collègues et nous le
devons aux françaises et aux Français et
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
Renaissance votera bien évidemment pour
le projet de lo de finan au côté de nos
collègues du MoDem et d'horizon je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tangui pour le groupe rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national ça je suis pas
sûr madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues 50
ans 50 longues années un demi-siècle que
les gouvernements qui se sont succédés
présentent systématiquement sans aucune
exception un budget en déficit je vous
l'ai dit en commission je vous le redis
ici 50 ans normalement quand on se marie
et qu'on s'aime c'est les nos d'or avec
vous pasain d'amour même platonique ce
sont bien les nosces de plomb 50 ans que
vous plombez notre pays par plus de
déficit plus de dettes toujours plus
d'impôts et pourtant moins de service pu
public efficace votre héritage au bout
de tant d'années c'est l'exaspération
fiscale de nos concitoyens face aux
injustices ce sont des familles et des
retraités qui ne peuvent vivre de leur
travail des classes moyennes prises
entre l'enclume de la cistana et le
marteau des privilèges oui vous les
macronistes et avant les fausses
alternances de gauche et de droite tous
vous n'avez jamais été capable
d'équilibrer les comptes publics malgré
un niveau de fiscalité et de prélèvement
obligatoire en perpétuel alourdissement
quel triste anniversaire pour la France
que ce nouveau cadeau empoisonné que
vous lui offrez en échange de la
confiance que nos concitoyens vous avez
pourtant accordé pour ces 50 ans de
déficit messieurs les ministres monsieur
le ministre pardon vous n'avez pas fait
les choses à moitié vous faites un
nouveau cadeau à la France de 285
milliards d'euros d'endettement 285
milliards d'euros voici le montant
vertigineux que le gouvernement va
emprunter en 2024 pour financer le
déficit public et le refinancement de la
dette un niveau record de 4 milliards
d'euros c'est presque 10 % du pb de la
France censé censé financer l'urrie C
tréle déficit que vous avez créé en
effet avec Emmanuel Macron la France
n'est pas seulement en déficite sur ses
comptes publics mais aussi un déficit
record commercial et dernier avatar de
votre incompétence un déficit sur la
balance des paiements bref chaque année
qui passe vous appauvrissez les Français
de toutes parts et il n'y a pas à
chercher ailleurs que dans votre incurie
la baisse historique du niveau de vie
des Français
vous êtes monsieur le ministre avec
Monsieur Macron avec cette minorité
présidentielle les femmes et les hommes
de tous les records des pires records
records d'endettement record
d'endettement qui suit évidemment
d'année en année des records de dette
qui suivent eux-mêmes des records de
déficit historique record d'impôts en
valeur absolue en valeur relative qui
cette année encore vont s'alourdir de 17
milliards d'euros en particulier les
impôts les plus injustes la TVA la
hausse des impôts est deux fois
supérieure à inflation elle est quatre
fois supérieure à la hausse de la
croissance attendue autrement dit le
raquette des classes moyennes et des
pmeue monsieur le ministre c'est quand
la mer se retire que l'on voit ceux qui
nagent nu c'est un mot d'esprit de
Warren Buffett un Mozart de la finance
un vrai pas vous me passerez la
palimitation contrefaite installée à
l'Élysée en effet le ruissolement de la
politique monétaire la seule qui existe
le ruissellement de la politique des
bandes centrales pendant près de 10 ans
avait noyer les économies occidentales
sous l'argent gratuit au mépris de
toutes les règles de prudence financière
et d'équilibre économique cette
véritable pyramide de Ponzi d'état vous
permettez monsieur le ministre et vos
prédécesseurs de maintenir à flot votre
gestion désastreuse avec les illusions
de tenir le coût de l'endettement par un
formidable coût d'esbrouf vous avez
continué à endetter la France tout en
semblant baisser le coût des intérêts
que vous versiez au marché financiers s
s'endetter toujours plus en semblant
payer moins voilà votre fameux argent
magique qu'Emmanuel Macron faisait
semblant dénoncer en parlant de notre
modèle social Vous dénoncez en fait à
voix haute ce que vous faites dans
l'ombre des Couloirs de Bercy quel
triste numéro des ulionistes mais
l'illusion a pris fin et maintenant vous
présenter la facture au français il est
d'ailleurs assez pathétique monsieur le
ministre CASNAV que vous traitiez par le
mépris et l'indifférence la volonté du
rassemblement national seul parti il est
vrai à vouloir discuter de la politique
monétaire et de la politique de la
Banque centrale c'est pathétique puisque
c'est bien la politique monétaire de la
Banque centrale européenne qui seule
vous a permis de gâcher votre compétence
et qui seulle est en train de la révéler
la facture exorbitante des engagements
financiers de l'État dans et déjà plus
de 60 milliards d'euros 2è budget d'
nation deviendra sans doute l'année
prochaine la première dépense de l'État
avec 71 milliards devant l'enseignement
scolaire face à un tel désastre vous
pourriez adopter une attitude modeste
vous inquiéter en appeler à des
solutions de rupture et surtout pourquoi
pas on peut rêver laisser des gens
laisser la place à des gens capables de
redresser la France maisainten non vous
vous enfermez dans vos certitudes vous
gargarisant de succès qui n'existe que
dans votre imagination faute de compte
public flatteur monsieur le ministre
mais je m'adresse aussi par l'esprit à
Bruno Le Maire vous en êtes réduit à
l'autoflattererie or comme disait la
roche fouco la flatterie est une fausse
monnaie qui n'a de cours que par votre
vanité cette autoflatterie ne vous sera
donc d'aucun secours pour rétablir les
comptes de la Nation d'aucun secours
pour rendre leur argent aux Français
vous n'aurez aucun secours non plus
monsieur le ministre casenav des
dialogues d' Bercy réunion aussi
interminables qu'inutiles de toute
évidence Monsieur le Maire invente des
résultats économiques imaginaires et
vous monsieur casazenav vous entendez
des voix des voix des oppositions qui
seraient d'accord avec vos propositions
les voix de Jean sauver la France les
voix de Thomas les conduiront à la ruine
je vous le dis il n'y a aucun rapport
entre ce que les entre ce que les
oppositions pardon ont demandé au
dialogue de Bery et les propositions
macronistes que vous voulez imposer sous
un consensus
imaginaire vous avez toujours cette même
prétention encore ce so voir vaniteuse à
poursuivre sous une autre forme de main
vos erreurs d'hier la même prétention à
vouloir appeler AR arc de la raison ce
qui n'est qu'une coalition de la
faillite de la dette et des impôts vous
conduisez tout simplement notre pays à
la banquroute face à la crise de
l'hyperinflation que ni les banques
centrales ni vous n'avez vu venir malgré
nos alertes les banques centrales
agissent mal mais elles agissent vite
elles ont augmenté leur taux faisant
envoler le coût de l'endettement de la
France endettement que vous avez
samment pardon consciencieusement
aggravé de la bagatelle de près de 800
milliards d'euros depuis qu'Emmanuel
Macron a pris les pouvo a pris le
pouvoir en France les EOS de l'argent
gratuit et abondant arrosant de
liquidité l'échec sans provision que
vous avez fait au français et vos
dépenses incontrôlées se sont retirées
mais qu'avez fait-vous en disant de tout
cet argent de tout ce temps où l'argent
coulait à flot avez-vous investi dans
notre industrie avez-vous investi dans
notre agriculture dans nos matières
premières stratégiques avez-vous vous
financez enfin un bon de notre recherche
etre de notre développement avez-vous
mis en place les formations techniques
et académiques nécessaires à l'économie
réelle lancer des programmes d'ampleur
pour notre production d'électricité
l'isolement de le logement ou une
transition écologique juste vers des
véhicules plus propres et moins cher non
rien absolument rien vous avez
strictement appliqué la fameuse
politique de la planche habillée vous
avez financé à perte des dépenses de
fonctionnement vous avez dépensé à
Pertre une politique de submersion
migratoire irresponsable vous avez
financé à per des budgets européens hors
contrôle des promesses clientélistes
pour acheter les élections et surtout
vous avez financé avec la dette de
l'argent et les impôts les privilèges
des oligarques les marges juteuses des
multinationales les prébandes de la
technocratie européenne et des
bureaucrates parasites en tout genre qui
vivent sur le dos des Français depuis
bien trop
[Applaudissements]
longtempsel le roi dans la fablepony
apparissez donc avec l'accord d'experts
en désinformation et de consultants en
faillite tel que vous êtes nu totalement
nu sans ressources désarmé et perdu vous
connaissez d'autres fables j'en suis sûr
monsieur le ministre et la première
d'entre elles a prise quand on le
faisait encore sur les bancs de l'école
de la République vous êtes la cigale
monsieur le ministre vous avez paradé
tout l'été et vous voilà bien dépourvu
puisque la bise est venue la bise de
l'hyperinflation souffle encore sur
l'économie française jeelant le pouvoir
d'achat des Français à un niveau
rarement vu la bise est venue monsieur
le ministre et vous avez besoin d'aller
crier famine au prix de l'oligarchie
votre voisine pour la prier de vous
prêter quelques euros pour subsister
jusqu'à la saison nouvelle mais Monsieur
le Maire l'oligarchie n'est pas prêteuse
et c'est là son moindre défaut
l'oligarchie est même ingrate malgré
tous les bienfaits que vous lui avez
portés vous avez protégé ses marges
écarté tout impôt de ses surprofits de
ces surdévidentes de ces surrachats
d'action elle ne vous rendra rien la
lumineuse Nino de l'enclos avait prédit
monsieur le ministre que l'ingratitude
des hommes est presque toujours le prix
égal de vos bienfaits voyez la fameuse
taxe sur les autoroutes que vous essayez
d' vainement d'imposer à l'escroquerie
organisée que constituent les contrats
de concession d'autoroute ces oligarques
veulent déjà ils le disent d'ailleurs
ils n'ont pas peur la répercuter sur les
automobilistes le RN vous demande
quelques garanties par amendement et
vous les refusez comme toujours car vous
vous préparez déjà à vous à vous
soumettre à l'injuste loi du plus fort
car oui monsieur le ministre ce que nous
savons déjà c'est que la macronie les
les intérêts de quelques particuliers
sont toujours plus forts que l'intérêt
général vous m'inspirez monsieur le
ministre des citations d'Ancien Régime
ce soir car votre gestion désastreuse
hasardeuse et injuste des finances
publiques me rappelle à bien des égards
la catastrophe des finances de la fin de
la royauté vous m'inspireer monsieur le
ministre le souvenir de Jacques Necker
plusieurs fois à la tête des finances
royales du début des années 1780 jusqu'à
la veille de la prise de la Bastille
votre premier point avec Necker c'est
cet étrange sentiment de compétence que
vous arrivez à maintenir malgré des
réformes absurdes des mesures ruineuses
des résultats
désastreux votre deuxème point commun
avec Necker c'est que vous commandez aux
privilégiés de minorer leur privilège en
vain l'année dernière j'alertaé votre
prédécesseur qui a connu un autre destin
et qui n'assumera pas vous avez pas de
chance ses propres erreurs le fait que
vous n'obtiendrez rien aucune faveur des
oligarques comme Necker vous refusez de
couper dans les dépenses structurelles
de l'État les prébandes les privilèges
de cours mais après tout votre
gouvernement n'est-il pas le plus cher
de l'histoire de la République comme
ncker faute de courage vous avez avez la
ruse et vous multipliez les expédients
financiers utilisant la dette jusqu'à
l'épuisement de la France comme n
d'ailleurs vous utilisez des expédients
les plus absurde Necker avait eu la
bonne idée si je puis dire de multiplier
les rentes viagèr à une époque où
l'espérance de vie augmenta vous aussi
vous avez l'idée de multiplier les bons
du Trésor indexé sur l'inflation en
pleine crise inflationniste voilà ve
deux génies d'incompét réunis par les
méandres de
l'histoire la seule différence monsieur
le ministre avec Neer et qu'il n'a
jamais utilisé le lit de justice royale
pour imposer sa volonté au Parlement
c'est l'équivalent du 493 vous vous avez
votre lit de justice Vous avez le 493
fidèle à la lettre de nos constitutions
Gaulistes mais pas à son esprit gaulien
puisqu'il avait été inventé pour
contraindre une majorité divisée jamais
pour contraindre les oppositions toute
notre discussion révèle donc d'une
pantomine d'un faux débat parlementaire
et de faux dialogue de Bery dont vous
avez le secret le budget il est déjà
écrit entre Matignon peut-être l'Élysée
sous le patronage de la la Commission
européenne et des agences de notation la
seule po politique la seule question
politique qui vaille ce soir et donc de
savoir si oui ou non les députés les
républicains censureront à terme ce
budget de la de faillite et ce budget
d'irresponsabilité l'année passée les
républicains mais vous serez librees de
faire ce que vous voulez avait laissé
passer la catastrophe budgétaire du
gouvernement avec la promesse je tiens
vous le rappeler quand même de ramener
le carburant à 1,5 le litre on sait
qu'elle l'avenir a eu cette promesse le
groupe rassemblement national aura le
courage encore de de censurer ce
gouvernement et de revenir aux urnes si
nécessaire comme nous avons le courage
de porter avec Marine Le Pen et Jordane
Bardella un tout autre chemin pour la
France ce chemin passe d'abord par
rendre leur argent français en
rétablissant un modèle fiscal juste où
les impôts diminuent en étant mieux
réparti oui le groupe rassemblement
national condamne le fait que depuis 50
ans vous avez fait de la TVA l'appau le
plus injuste le pilier du financement de
la France oui nous voulons encore et
toujours rétablir la justice fiscale en
passant la TVA de 20 à 55 sur
l'électricité le gaz le file les
carburants ainsi que tout autre produit
de première nécessité tout en supprimant
pour 100 produits d'alimentation et
d'hygiène la TVA sur ces produits
contrairement je dois le dire au
mensonges d'État que vous répandez la
baisse de la TVA sur les produits
concurrentiels fonctionne parfaitement
la Banque centrale du Portugal vient de
confirmer par un rapport que la baisse
de 6 points décidé par ce gouvernement
avait parfaitement fonctionné ce n'est
pas un allié du RN c'est un gouvernement
du gauche de gauche qui l'a fait elle
rappelle ce gouvernement de gauche
pourra rappeler quelques leçons
d'économie populaire à laanupes nos
mesures de justesse fiscale sont
multiples maintien des jeunes talents en
supprimant l'impôt sur revenu pour les
moins de 30 ans demipart fiscale des
veuves politique familiale meilleure
transmission du travail de toute une vie
nous défendons et nous défendrons
toujours les valeurs d'enracinement que
nous portons il s'agit aussi de relancer
une politique du logement qui favorise
l'accès à la propriété à la construction
avec des mesures qui cherchent à aider
les mén et les entreprises en cessant de
les contraindre avec des règles absurdes
et des leçons de morale nos concitoyens
n'ont pas besoin des macronistes pour
savoir où quand et comment ils veulent
vivre pour financer les allègements de
taxes sur les classes moyennes et
populaires il faut répartir la charge
sur les multinationales et ceux qui
spéculent sur les marchés plutôt que de
créer de la de la valeur ici comme
ailleurs nos mesures ne sont pas
seulement de la bonne gestion elles ont
un contenu politique elles veulent
encourager la création de richesse sur
le sol national et taxer les pratiques
toxiques à ce titre je ne cache pas ma
satisfaction de voir le retournement de
veste de la macronie sur les sprofits
des majeurs de l'énergie ou les rachats
d'action en dehors de quelques députés
de la majorité je tiens les saluer
clairvoyant et de bonne foi que que que
n'avons-nous pardon entendu quand Marine
Le Pen la première il y a 2 ans proposé
de taxer les surachats d'action et de
taxer les surprofits par ailleurs si la
première par ailleurs dans le même
courage que nous aurons à rétablir la
justice fiscale nous aurons du courage
pour pour baisser les dépenses
structurelles contrairement à ce que
vous dites vous ne réalisez aucune
mesure d'économie puisque vous ne
baissez même pas les dépenses au rapport
du bouclier énergétique que vous avez
supprimé avec vous les mesures qui
devent être exceptionnelles se
transforment en gabgie perpétuelle aussi
nous aurons le courage de nous attaquer
au vages sacrés de votre politique la
politique migratoire en priorité les
milliards consacrés au maintien des
clandestins le coût délirant de l'Union
européenne à qui nous avons verser
encore 12 milliards d'euros en en
contribution nette 10 milliards en 2022
la contribution brut cette année comme
par magie quelques mois avant les
européennes baisse mais elle explosera
l'année prochaine à 27 milliards d'euros
nous avons le courage de lutter contre
la suradministration nous donnons des
exemples d'économie en supprimant des
agences supprimer la creux l'arcepp ou
encore les ARS elles ne servent à rien
ell ne pour elles ne font que ce que
pourrait faire l'administration centrale
ou nos administrations déconcentrées
nous aurons donc ce courage de lutter
aussi pleinement contre la fraude les
abus ce courage nous l'avons et c'est
courage c'est ce qui vous manque donc
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général cessez de critiquer
vos opposition sur le manque de
proposition prenez votre courage à la
main auain dans vos mains pardon ayez le
courage de vous présenter non pas à une
censure imaginaire des républains mais
au des Français présentez votre Budet
devant les es on verra ce qu'ils en
pens la parole est à Monsieur David
guireud pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise
bien
Madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres ch
collègues je voulais d'abord commencer
par remercier tous nos collègues de la
commission des
finances le rapporteur général le
président de la commission des finances
pour avoir su maintenir pendant des
débats en commission malgré les forts
désaccords la forte tension qui règne
aujourd'hui dans le pays un cadre de
travail sérieux pour parler au fond de
comment on gère nos finances publiques
je tenais à vous remercier en premier
lieu pour ça sur le
reste c'est toujours difficile de
préparer un discours sur le projet de
loi de finance avec vous parce que à
peine on a commencé à écrire et c'est
déjà le le
festival une collègue d'horizon disait
tout à l'heure sur la motion de
rejet nous accuser de vouloir priver le
débat j'espère quand même que vous allez
répéter ça à madame la Première ministre
quand elle va débarquer dans quelques
heures ou dans un jour ou deux pour nous
empêcher de voter et de débattre sur le
projet de loi de finance et sur la
partie de des
recettes j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses
de la part des ministres c'est un projet
sérieux qu'on est à l'euro
près
c'est deux mots que vous avez à la
bouche le sérieux budgétaire bah votre
projet de loi de finance il est pas
sérieux les prévisions de croissance
vous avez pas arrêté de les modifier au
début on était à 18 maintenant on est à
14 alors que
l'OFCE la Banque de France
nous disent que les prévisions de
croissance elles sont pas bonnes elles
sont à 0,8 % 0,9 % une paille quoi juste
quelques dizaines de milliards d'euros
sur les prévisions
d'inflation ça fait des années que le
ministre Bruno Lemer court après le pic
de l'inflation il gravit il gravit ça ne
s'arrête jamais ça fait 2 ans qu'on est
censé être dans le pic de
l'inflation mais Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
a visiblement perdu son oxygène à force
de gravir ce
pic
quant au rassemblement national parce
que j'ai entendu quelque interpellation
là-bas je dois bien vous dire
que à force de vouloir toujours être en
hauteur on vous a perdu de vue on sait
même plus ce que vous proposez pour le
pays vous étiez trois en permanence en
commission là vous êtes à votre pic vous
êtes 10 le seul soir où il y aura pas de
vote sur ce projet de loi je vous
félicite j'en viens
aux arguments qui nous ont été
présentés j'entends le refrain depuis
quelques
années que votre politique aurait eu un
impact formidable parce que les recettes
de l'impôt sur les sociétés ça se voit
ont
augmenté c'est une fake
news il y a deux choses qui sont passé
pour pour expliquer l'augmentation des
recettes de l'impôt sur les sociétés
d'abord en
2018 vous avez transformé le crédit
d'impôt le cice en allègement pérenne de
cotisation sociale donc c'est plus le
budget qui s'est mis à financer c'est
plus le budget de l'État qui s'est mis à
financer ce cadeau fiscal vous l'avez
transféré à la sécurité sociale c'est
pour ça qu'on se retrouve en 2021 avec
un rendement de l'impôt sur les sociétés
qui retrouve son niveau à peu près
d'avant le cice c'est-à-dire 46 46
milliards d'euros euh en 2021 de
recettes grâce au euh de recettes d'impô
sur les sociétés en 2013 elles étaient
de 47 milliards d'euros alors il y a eu
ce phénomène de rattrapage et puis il y
a autre chose cette autre chose ça
s'appelle
l'inflation le rendement de l'impôt sur
les sociétés s'il atteint aujourd'hui un
montant de 62 milliards d'euros c'est
beaucoup mais c'est parce queil y a des
boîtes dans ce pays qui se sont fait des
super profits qui se sont fait des
marges sur l'inflation et que le projet
de loi de finance lui-même il explique
cette hausse de de l'impô sur les
sociétés en raison du fort dynamisme du
bénéfice fiscal en
2023 vous êtes en train de vous
féliciter du fait que des entreprises
notamment des grandes boîtes ce soit
tout simplement fait de l'argent sur le
dos des
Français cette hausse des prix là
elle a pas entraîné de surplu d'activité
ça n'est pas
vrai ce que vous auriez pu faire par
contre au lieu de vous gargariser
d'avoir rien fait vous auriez pu ne
serait-ce que pour les grandes boîtes
pour les grands groupes
revenir sur un taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés à 33 % comme ça l'était avant
le kakena Macron là je vous assure que
vous auriez eu des rentrées fiscal
conséquente pour réarmer nos services
publics c'est pas le choix que vous avez
fait et puis sur les impôt sur les
entreprises je tiens à rappeler quand
même que en 2019 par
exemple l'impôt sur les sociétés il pèse
moins en France que dans le restque de
l'OCDE la France c'est pas un enfer
fiscal pour les boîtes c'est un paradis
fiscal 2 % du PIB pour la France contte
3,3 % du PIB en moyenne pour les autres
pays et je pense que si on intègre les
cadeaux fiscaux qui ont été fait depuis
2019 l'écart il est encore plus
considérable alors par quoi se
caractérise votre
budget par des rentrées
considérables plus de 200 milliards
d'euros d'argent issu de la TVA 200
milliards
d'euros mais dans ces 200 milliards
d'euros on les retrouve pas total budget
de l'État pourquoi parce qu'ils ont été
transférés à la sécurité sociale pour
compenser en parti les gigantesques
exonération de cotisation sociale que
vous avez fait au grand groupe de ce
pays le montant faut quand même se
rendre compte des chiffres parce que
c'est
exponentiel le montant qui éta transféré
à la sécurité sociale de 2013 à 2018 y a
pas si longtemps c'est environ 10
milliards d'euros par an
là en ce moment le montant de TVA qui a
été transféré à la sécurité sociale pour
l'année 2022 c'est 57 milliards d'euros
c'est 5 fois plus que sur les quinquenas
d'avant Emmanuel
Macron pour un total de 100 milliards
d'euros de TVA dans le
budget on a plus de 100 autres milliards
d'euros qui sont transférés à la CC aux
collectivités locales j'ai entendu tout
à l'heure un ministre je crois que
c'était monsieur casenav qui nous disait
ceci on d'opposer l'État aux
collectivités locales c'est exactement
ce que je dirais si j'étais en train
d'opposer l'État aux collectivités
locales parce que c'est ce que vous
faites vous êtes en train d'assécher les
financements autonomees des
collectivités locales avec les impôts de
production elles n'ont plus ces rentrées
d'argent là vous compensez comment avec
l'argent de la TVA mais ça pour les
collectivités locales ça veut dire plus
d'autonomie ça veut dire dépendance de
l'État en terme de financement publ ça
veut dire la mise sous coupe
démocratique de la perfusion de l'État
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça pour
la sécurité sociale c'est pareil il y a
un problème
démocratique on ne peut pas mêler aussi
fortement trois budgets distinct que
sont le budget des collectivités
territoriales le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et le budget de l'État c'est
malsin et c'est exactement ce que vous
êtes en train de faire c'est malsin
démocratiquement et même monsieur
Moscovici
qui n'est pas un de nos amis qui ne
partage pas nos thèses le reconnaissez
il y a peu en commission des
finances c'est un problème aussi
économique et social parce que ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que l'entièreté
de votre politique économique en terme
de recette elle consiste à faire
financer par les classes moyennes et par
les classes populaires les cadeaux que
vous faites au grand groupes nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec cette logique
l'argent issu de la consommation
populaire il devrait revenir dans le
budget de l'État pour soutenir la
consommation populaire ou pour soutenir
les services publics ou pour booster par
exemple certaines dépenses de services
public qui pourraient aider le pays à se
relever mais c'est exactement l'inverse
que vous êtes en train de faire alors si
vous tenez tant que ça à la limite à vos
exonérations de cotisation si vous y
tenez tant que ça mais dans ce cas-là
fait un choix politique faites le choix
de faire financer ces exonérations sur
autre chose que les classes moyennes et
populaires par exemple
sur les plus riches de ce pays voyez là
ça sera un choix politique à faire
maintenant vous avez fait le choix
siamant de faire financer toute cette
politique économique proentreprise comme
vous dites à ceux qui galèrent le plus
en ce moment à remplir leur cadis à
remplir leur frigo à payer leur taxes à
payer leur énergie bah ça c'est pas
normal c'est une injustice de classe
parce que votre budget est un budget de
classe un budget
antiredistributif un budget qui met à
mal la sécurité sociale qui met à mal
les les collectivités territoriales et
qui met à mal en vérité le pouvoir
d'achat des
Français et puis surtout dans ce projet
de loi de finance il y a quelque chose
qui qui a éclaté aux yeux de tout le
monde en commission vous êtes
minoritaire vous êtes minoritaire jusque
dans votre
majorité vous êtes incapable même
d'écouter vos propres alliés parce que
vous allez faire un 49 temps on sait que
vous allez pas les
reprendre l'augmentation de la taxe sur
les transactions financières on aurait
pu la faire si vous cherchez de l'argent
pour par ex pour financer vos
exonérations de cotisation on l'a voté
ça aurait pu rapporter 11 milliards
d'euros à l'État sur les transactions
financières mais qui peut être contre ça
dans la période
actuelle l'impôt universel ciblé pour
taxer tous les Français ou qu'il soi
comme le font les Américains on aurait
pu le faire on l'a voté vous allez
l'enlever du 49 avec le 493 le
rétablissement de l'exit taxe c'était
même pas notre idée c'est une
proposition qu'on défend mais c'est pas
nous qui l'avons défendu en commission
c'est quelqu'un de votre majorité vous
allez le virer
la taxation des super dividendes vous
allez le virer la taxe sur les rachats
d'action le versement mobilité pour que
pour éviter que les Français notamment
les Franciliens VO le prix de leur passe
Navigo augmenté vous allez
l'enlever alors comment on
fait parce que la vérité des recettes de
l'État c'est que vous nous dites qu'il y
a pas d'argent après il y a pas d'argent
pour financer les services publics il y
a pas d'argent pour financer la
transition écologique on vous dit qu'il
y a S taxes en plus 100 milliards
d'euros qui sont immédiatement
mobilisables avec l'argent de la TVA ça
mériterait de vous faire réfléchir mais
non vous n'y pensez même pas c'est même
pas un sujet c'est même plus un sujet de
discussion démocratique pour
vous la caricature chers
collègues moi la caricature c'est quand
Monsieur Bruno Leem le ministre nous dit
qu'on faire un déluge fiscal alors que
c'est des propositions de bon sens mais
vous savez quoi je préfère un déluge
fiscal que la s parce que les Français
ils se remettront pas de la sécheresse
sur les finances publiques ils seen
remettront
pas parce qu'on a besoin de professeurs
on a besoin d'hôpital public on a besoin
de contrôleur des douanes on a besoin de
tout ça alors plutôt le déluge pour
financer correctement des professeurs
des soignants remettre en état nos
hôpitaux rénover nos commissariats
plutôt que se dire qu'il y a pas assez
d'argent et que du coup on laisse tout
tomber et qu'il y a des coins entiers en
France o tout est laissé tomber ça
devrait d'ailleurs concerner vos
circonscriptions je croyais que vous en
aviez quelque chose à
faire au gouvernement qui a dit tout à
l'heure que la nation doit se
reconstruire par le travail et par
l'effort nous vous recommandons
d'appliquer pour vous-même ces principes
parce que c'est pas sérieux d'être aussi
aléatoire d'être aussi
approximatif dans l'engagement des
dépenses dans le financement dans les
prévisions vous nous dites il y a pas de
majorité alternative mais déjà le
premier fait c'est qu'il y a pas de
majorité c'est que toutes vos
oppositions vous disent que vos
projections de croissance elles sont pas
sincères et vous nous dites qu'il faut
vous croire mais depuis des années elles
sont pas sincères et l'expérience nous
montre pas un sentiment pas un instinct
l'expérience nous montre que vous êtes
planté lamentablement notamment sur les
prévisions d'inflation donc vous devriez
commencer par écouter vos opposition qui
vous disent que tant qu'il y aura des
prévisions de croissance et d'inflation
qui sont pas sérieuses et ben on peut
pas faire passer un budget comme ça
parce que derrière ça veut dire une cure
d'austérité sans précédent parce que
derrière ça veut dire que nos services
publics sont désarmés parce que derrière
ça veut dire tellement de choses que
vous ne semblez malheureusement pas
enclin à écouter le déficit va baisser
nous a dit Monsieur le Ministre CASNAV
non le déficit il va pas
baisser quand les collectivités
territoriales elles sont à l'os alors
que c'est les premiers investisseurs du
pays et ben les les dépenses ça va pas
revenir l'activité va pas revenir vous
avez vu l'état du logement de la
construction
vous voyez bien que c'est pas le marché
là qui peut régler le problème c'est
l'état c'est un investissement
conséquent dans la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments dans le bâtiment et si on
ne met pas l'argent de la Suu là-dedans
ça ne se fera pas parce que il y a un
des dogmes sur lequel vous êtes aveuglé
que vous ne comprenez pas le marché ne
peut plus régler les soubressau les
tremblement économique qui est en train
d'affronter notre pays c'est la
puissance publique c'est la solidarité
c'est la redistribution des
richesses ces mots vous sont peut-être
inconnus mais votre monde idéologique
est en train de s'effondrer alors encore
une fois on sait ce qui va se passer
vous allez nous dire qu'on est à l'euro
près le déficit va continuer de baisser
vous allez nous dire qu'on est à l'uro
près vous serez forcé de faire survivre
quelques services public parce que sinon
l'état s'écroule la société française
s'écroule parce que la manière dont
s'est construit notre pays c'est avec un
service public fort avec des gens dans
le service public qui tiennent debout
pendant les périodes de crise pendant le
covid pendant qu'à chaque fois il faut
défendre les conditions de vie des
Français voilà ce que vous manquez c'est
un peu dommage c'est un peu dommage de
pas être
écouté on aurait aimé aller à autre
chose mais vous nous laissez pas d'autre
choix vu qu' va y avoir un 493 et qu'on
pourra même pas voter sur des
propositions vous allez tout prendre et
tout jeter vous nous laissez pas d'autre
choix que faire la motion de censure et
que d'assumer qu'en effet pour changer
d'optique pour changer de monde pour
faire en sorte que la France elle
redevienne solidaire et qu'elle
redistribue les richesses nous devons
vous faire tomber et nous vous ferons
tomber nous y sommes prêt avec la motion
de censure que nous
déposerons je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Véronique louvagi pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues ce budget 2024 est le 50èe
consécutif en déficite mais il restera
comme le budget de record en terme de
dett et de déficit mes chers collègues
tous les signaux budgétaires ont atteint
un seuil d'alerte inédit notre dette
dépasse désormais les 3000 milliards
d'euros c'est près de 45000 € de dett
par français depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron nous avons même
accumulé 1000 milliards d'euros de
dettes en plus la note de la France est
de se fait déjà dégradée par l'agence
Fitch alors que la France risque de
faire l'objet d'une procédure de
surveillance de l'Union européenne pour
déficit excessif la France s'apprête à
lever
285 milliards d'euros sur les marchés un
record absolu et ce alors que les taux à
10 ans sont à leur niveau le plus haut
depuis 2012 notre dette nous coûte de
plus en plus cher la charge des intérêts
de la dette était de 31 milliards en
2021 elle est de 57 milliards en 2024 et
pourrait dépasser les 81 milliards en
2027 c'est devenu et de loin le poste de
dépense le plus important de l'État
malgré tous ces indicateurs plus
qu'alarmant ce budget est une nouvelle
fois hélas celui de renoncement en terme
de maîtrise de nos comptes publics
renoncement en premier lieu à la baisse
des dépenses en effet les baisses de
dépenses réelles s'élèvent péniblement à
2 milliards d'euros en 2024 très loin
des 16 milliards d'euros présentés et
dont 14,4 milliards d'euros donc la
quasi-ttalité correspond à l'extinction
prévu de dépenses exceptionnelles vous
l'avez d'ailleurs vous-même dit monsieur
le ministre en retenant un chiffre de 14
milliards très loin des 15 milliards
d'euros de baisse de dépenses que vous
nous aviez présenté en juin dans le
cadre des Assises des finances publiques
et ce qui est révélateur de votre
difficulté finalement à réussir à
baisser les dépenses c'est que déjà dès
maintenant vous abordez la question du
PLF 2025 sur les 12 milliards d'euros
d'économie qui devront être réalisés
pour autant à côté de cela les annonces
de nouvelles dépenses se multiplient
vous nous promettiez la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte mais la réalité c'est que
les dépenses publiques progresseront en
2024 davantage que ce que recommande
l'Union européenne et pourtant ce projet
de loi de finance n'acte en rien une
baisse des impôts des Français pas plus
qu'il ne répond à la crise du pouvoir
d'achat ou à la crise du logement
renoncement au désendettement ensuite
malgré l'explosion de la charge de la
dette le désendettement espéré n'est
absolument plus ou pas à l'ordre du jour
la réduction de la dette de seulement
4atre points d'ici 2027 est même
qualifiée je cite d'homéopathique par le
président du Haut Conseil des finances
publiques renoncement à la baisse du
nombre d'agents publics Emmanuel Macron
promettait de réduire de 50000 le nombre
de fonctionnaires en 5 ans sur la sphère
de l'état non seulement cette promesse
n'a jamais été tenu mais il a même fait
tout l'inverse le nombre de
fonctionnaires va encore de nouveau
augmenter avec
8273 postes supplémentaires en plus en
2024 qui font suite au 11000 postes
supplémentaires en plus en
2023 renoncement enfin à la baisse du
déficit nous serons en 2026 le dernier
pays d'Europe à ne pas être redescendu
sous la barre des 3 % de déficit et
encore ces chiffres de dettes de déficit
sont controversés par des hypothèses de
croissance optimistes et très supérieure
à celle du consensus des économistes
mais parce que les républicains se
doivent de présenter une vision
alternative de ce que devraient être les
orientations budgétaire de notre pays
nous avons construit un contre budget un
contrebudget qui permet de présenter
cette alternative je me feraiis un
plaisir à l'issue de mon intervention de
vous remettre un exemplaire monsieur le
ministre et j'espère que vous vous en
inspirez si vous l'avez déjà j'espère
que vous l'avez lu avec attention dans
ce cadre nous les républicains nous
proposons 1 de réduire le fardeau fiscal
pour 10,8 milliards d'euros pour tenir
compte du fait qu'effectivement notre
taux de prélèvement obligatoire est un
des plus élevés d'Europe pour ne pas
dire le plus élevé derrière le Danemark
de assurer un objectif de redistribution
vers les familles en faveur du logement
pour 2,4 milliards d'euros 3 enfin de
mieux maîtriser les dépenses en
travaillant sur leur efficacité avec des
économies qui sont proposées pour 25
milliards d'euros ces baisses des impôts
nous les destinons aux Français aux
Français qui travaillent en diminuant la
taxe sur les carburants pour tous les
Français entraînant une économie de 5 €
pour un plein de 50 L et c'est une
mesure pérenne et à destination de tous
les Français car tous ont été frappés ou
sont frappés par l'envolet des prix à la
pompe et ce n'est pas un chèque à
destination de quelques-uns ces baisse
d'impôts et ces redistribution nous les
destinons également aux familles en
réhaussant les plafonds du cootient
familial pour revenir sur des
dispositions qui avaient été remise en
cause en 2013 et 2014 et nous
rétablissons l'universalité des
allocations familiales là encore pour
soutenir les familles et pour tenir
compte de de notre situation
catastrophique en terme de natalité nous
proposons par ailleurs de répondre
également à la très violente crise du
logement qui est actuelle et qui est
encore devant nous en favorisant les
donations quand elles sont fléchées vers
l'acquisition d'une résidence principale
en réduisant les droits de succession
comme le promettait lui-même le
président de la République et notamment
en maintenant le prêt à taux zéro dans
sa forme existante et en le déclinant à
une plus grande échelle ces baisses
d'impôt nous les destinons également aux
entreprises en proposant au gouvernement
de tenir sa promesse en accélérant la
suppression de la CVAE et ce alors que
la réindustrialisation de notre pays
doit être érigée en prié priorité
absolue ces mesures seront financées par
d'importantes économies à hauteur de 25
milliards d'euros travers 17 mesures que
je ne pourrais pas ici toutes détailler
nous proposons notamment dans nos
amendements de plafonner le crédit
d'impôt recherche puisqu'il ne faut
intervenir sur cette dépense qui ne c
cesse de croître et dont la la
trajectoire est relativement importante
nous proposons de réduire la niche
fiscale qui profite trop généreusement
aux armateurs notamment à la CMA CGM ou
de restreindre également l'aide médicale
d'État aux seules dépenses d'urgence
l'aide médicale d'État qui devient une
dépense insoutenable mais au-delà de
cette première partie du PLF nous vous
recommandons entre autres de revoir
l'indemnisation chômage de mettre en
place une allocation sociale unique pour
réduire le coût des prestations sociales
de limiter les dépenses consacrées à
l'hébergement d'urgence ou de mieux
encadrer le coût des opérateurs de
l'État je veux avoir un petit mot sur le
coût des opérateurs de l'État rappelez
que en 2019 le coût des opérateurs de
l'État c'était 50 milliards d'euros en
2023 c'est
76,6 milliards d'euros en 2019 c'était
400000 agents en 2023 c'est quasiment
408000 agents donc je crois que sur
cette question des opérateurs de l'État
nous devons nous apesantir et cela me me
permet de répondre à monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire je suis persuadé
que vous lui retransmettrez cette
réponse qui espérait avoir une réponse
au procès qui nous a été fait au procès
que la majorité nous a fait sur le
soi-disant coup des amendement des
députés les républicains et vous pourrez
constater que certaines mesures comme
celles que je viens d'évoquer qu'il
s'agisse de l'indemnisation chômage la
mise en place d'une allocation sociale
unique ou de mieux encadrer le coût des
opérateurs de l'État ne peuvent figurer
dans la première partie du PLF et je
pense que le procès qui nous a été fait
est vraiment un procès que je
qualifierais entre guillemets de facieux
et je pense que vous le reconnaîtrez
vous-même l'année passée vous nous aviez
rétorqué que nos propositions d'économie
au travers notre plan de sobriété
bureaucratique proposé dans le PLF 2023
n'était pas documenté n'était pas
précisé alors voilà vous voyez là toutes
nos mesures toutes nos propositions sont
maintenant sur la table elles sont
chiffrées documentées sérieuses mais
juste vous redire monsieur le ministre
si vous voulez baisser les impôts si
vous voulez résister aux sirènes de la
gauche qui demande encore plus d'impôts
qui demande toujours encore encore des
impôts vous ne pourrez le faire qu'en
engageant cette nécessaire et
indispensable baisse des dépenses
publiques si vous n'engagez pas cette
baisse des dépenses publiques vous ne
pourrez pas maintenir le niveau d'impôt
et vous ne pourrez pas baisser les
impôts nous vous avons fait des
propositions saisissez-vous de celle-ci
notre pays en sortira grandi hélas nous
risquons de ne pas pouvoir débattre sur
aucune de ces questions puisque le 493
viendra probablement clore la discussion
alors que les débats auront tout juste
débuté n'aurons donc pas l'occasion de
débattre sur les l'ensemble de nos
proposition pour toutes ces raisons et
parce que nous dénonçons à la fois le
contenu de ce PLF également ses
conditions d'examen les députés les
républicains combattront fermement et
avec ténacité ce budget je vous remercie
je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Pascal
Lecamp pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président la
Commission des finances monsieur
rapporteur général je dois tout d'abord
vous dire que passer en tribune après
Véronique louvagie et avant Christine
pierrezbone pour un député débutant
c'est impressionnant et ça force et ça
force et ça force
l'humidité alors à mon tour je souhaite
aussi remercier le rapporteur général le
président de la commission et surtout
l'ensemble
des des des administrateurs de la de la
commission des finances pour avoir
réussi pendant 4 jours jusqu'à tard dans
l' vendredi à tenir des débats de haute
qualité qui ont fait avancer si ce n'est
les décisions au moins les réflexions
alors comme l'année dernière nous sommes
réunis pour examiner le projet de loi de
finance pour l'année qui suit et comme
l'année dernière j'ai la nette
impression qu'il n'est pas inutile de
rappeler le rôle d'un tel texte même si
nous sommes assez peu nombreux un projet
de loi de finance ça doit être une
feuille de route pour l'année à venir
une concrétisation de transition de
politique publique la matérialisation de
l'accompagnement des Françaises et des
Français dans leur quotidien le
renforcement du cadre qui permet à nos
entreprises de l'agriculture au service
de la TPE à la grande entreprise de se
développer la démonstration de notre
attachement à la souveraineté économique
de la France à la stabilité financière
européenne des réponses aux défis qui
sont les nôtres aujourd'hui tels que le
pouvoir d'achat des Français le logement
et bien sûr la transition écologique une
loi de finance pour être tout seul en
même temps pour être crédible face à
cette complexité immense doit être
porteuse d'équilibre or certains ici
voudraient comme viennent de le faire
avant monsieur Tangui et Monsieur
guireud dans des registres différents
que l'on écrive un budget comme on le
rêve sans contraintte sans limite en
répondant à toutes les sollicitations
sans priorisation en répondant à chaque
problème par une taxe ou un crédit
d'impôt c'est selon les affinités
j'allais dire élective en Nant les
principes économique les plus
élimentaires ce qui guide chaque ménage
chaque jour pour son propre budget je
veux le dire très sérieusement c'est
irresponsable c'est irresponsable car
c'est mentir aux Français ces budgets
fantasmés que certains appellent de leur
vœux ne peuvent pas exister la réalité
d' faits s'impos toujours j'en veux pour
preuve que les critiques nombreuses qui
sont faites à la majorité depuis plus de
6 ans n'ont faitmerger émerger à ce
stade aucun à aucun moment une
alternative crédible cette réalité des
faits permettez-moi de vous la rappeler
comme l'a fait Madame Véronique louvagi
d'ailleurs qui vient de partir au 1emer
trimestre 2023 nous avons dépassé les
3000 milliards d'euros de dette la note
de la France qui signale sa crédibilité
financière a été dégradée par l'agence
Finch pour 2023 l'inflation atteindra
4,8 %. elle entraîne dans son sillage
des taux d'intérêt à la hausse en
conséquence en 2027 avec 71 milliards
d'euros la charge de la dette sera la
première dépense de l'État tout ça c'est
vrai alors il faut faire des choix et
c'est ce que nous faisons courageusement
et avec lucidité dans ce PLF nous avons
décidé de protéger l'emploi et le
pouvoir d'achat des Français face à la
pandémie covid et à la crise énergétique
mais le temps est venu enfin de tourner
la page de l'urgence et de retrouver le
chemin de la pérennité ce budget est
suit de la responsabilité budgétaire de
la maîtrise des dépenses il amorce notre
trajectoire de diminution des déficits
publics en le ramenant à 4,4 % dès 2024
tout en travaillant avec des marges de
manœuvre mince puisque près d'un/3 des
crédits 1/3 et bien des crédits sur le
PLF 2024 sont en fait déjà fixés par les
différentes lois de programmation que
nous avons adopté ici ce budget porte
par ailleurs une très forte ambition en
faveur de la transition écologique le
plus vert jamais présenté jusqu'à l'ORS
il comporte 39,7 milliards d'euros de
dépenses favorables à l'environ
soit 7 % des dépenses qui agiront
directement sur la protection de
l'environnement et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique il concrétise
le plan épargne avenir climat il
instaure le crédit d'impôt industrie
verte et il coupe dans les dépenses
fiscales brunes tout en accompagnant les
secteurs concerné au premier des rang au
premier rang desquels nos agriculteurs
en ce qui les concerne monsieur le enfin
Monsieur le Maire n'est pas là mais je
suppose que notre ministre des Finances
a omis tout à l'heure dans son annonce
sur les réseau consulaire celui des
chambres d'agriculture pour lequel
l'augmentation du plafond qui avait été
annoncé à cournom est indispensable à la
mise en place en 2024 de la LOA à
laquelle comme vous le savez le groupe
démocrate est très attaché ce budget est
aussi celui de la lutte contre les
fraudes il datent les administrations
des moyens de lutter contre ces
comportements inacceptables qui minent
un peu plus jour après jour le contrô
social qui nous lit voici donc ce qu'est
le budget 2024 un budget post-crise qui
permet de regarder vers l'avenir et qui
malgré le périmètre cont qui est le
nôtre pour des ambitions dont nous
pouvons être fiers tout en respectant
l'exercice imposé d'un retour progressif
de déficit en dessous des 3 % en 2027
dans ce cadre ainsi fixé les priorités
du groupe démocrate sont claires
adresser de premières réponses efficace
à la crise du logement à laquelle notre
pays fait face ainsi que proposer des
mesures en faveur d'une plus grande
justice fiscale nous souhaitons enrichir
ce texte en ce sens enfin en synthèse si
qualifier ce budget en TR mots je dirais
que ce budget est un budget d'action de
durabilité et d'équilibre dans ce
contexte et avec la responsabilité qui
nous caractérise le groupe démocrate
votera pour la première partie de ce
projet de loi de finance je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercieci la parole est à Madame
Christine pierzb pour le groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous nous retrouvons pour débuter
l'examen de la deuxè loi de finances
initiale de cette mandature qui sans
surprise fera l'objet comme la première
d'un nouveau 493 car comme tout
parlementaire je ne peux me réjouir du
recours à cet article qui prive la la la
représentation nationale de débat mais
je voudrais saluer le président de la
commission des finances le rapporteur
général et tous les membres de la
commission car nous avons pu débattre
des sujets importants en commission dans
une ambiance apaisée même si le temps
nous a manqué pour examiner tous les
sujets avant d'aborder le projet de loi
de finances pour 2024 permettez-moi de
dire quelques mots sur sur la loi de
programmation des finances publiques que
le gouvernement a je le rappelle fait
adopter en nouvelle lecture par
l'Assemblée nationale avec le 493 cette
loi qui fixe la trajectoire budgétaire
de notre pays jusqu'en 2027 n'est pas
réaliste selon nous elle est synonyme
pour les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes de sacrific que nous ne
pouvons pas cautionner le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour tous y compris pour ceux qui
n'en avaient pas besoin implique
aujourd'hui que vous demandiez des
efforts à tous y compris à celles et
ceux qui n'en ont pas les moyens nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec cette politique
qui n'a pas eu le courage de cibler les
aides préférant des mesures généralistes
à l'image de la baisse de 18 centimes
puis 30 centimes puis 10 centimes sur le
litre du carburant en 2022 y compris
pour ceux qui gagnaient par exemple plus
de 10000 € par mois ce qui a privé le
budget de l'État de 7,5 milliards
d'euros soit 15 % du budget 2022 alloué
à la transition écologique la la
priorité doit-elle être au redressement
des finances publiques ou à la
protection des Français nous faisons
clairement le choix de la deuxième
option la seule qui permette la cohésion
de la nation j'en viens maintenant au
budget 2024 le groupe socialiste est en
total désaccords avec les hypothèses sur
lesquelles vous avez élaboré ce budget
nous les jugeons beaucoup trop
optimistes et monsieur le ministre je le
dis sincèrement j'espère me tromper ce
budget il est non seulement irréaliste
mais il est également vous me
pardonnerez l'expression à côté de la
plaque il fait fausse route parce qu'il
ne permet pas de répondre aux priorités
et aux urgences des Françaises et des
Français et pour illustrer mon propos
j'aborderai successivement quatre
urgences d'abord le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation continue d'amputer
cruellement le pouvoir d'achat de nombre
de Français alors oui certains s'en
sortent très bien mais beaucoup de nos
compatriotes qui pourtant travaillent ou
bénéficient d'une pension de retraite
bien méritée n'arrive plus à vivre
dignement 30 jours par mois trouvez-vous
normal qu'après 40 ans de la beur cette
retraité ayant tout juste de quoi vivre
ne puisse plus gâter ses petits enfants
ou qu'une auxiliaire de vie qui prend sa
voiture tous les jours pour visiter C ou
six personnes âgées parfois deux fois
par jour gagnent tout juste le SMIC et
vivent moins bien aujourd'hui qu'en 2019
non monsieur le ministre la misère n'est
pas une fatalité j'ai en mémoire les
déclarations de Monsieur le Maire sur
l'inflation et je le cite nous
travaillons sur un scénario principal
celui de la baisse de l'inflation à
partir de la fin de l'année 2022 c'était
le 8 février 2022 sur France
interre et malheureusement non seulement
l'inflation fin 2022 n'avait pas reflué
mais elle s'est maintenue à un niveau
très élevé au premier semestre 2023 nous
avons auditionné vous le savez il y a 15
jours les associations car ittive à la
commission des finances toutes nous ont
dit avoir arrivé en masse de nouveaux
bénéficiaires pire encore pour la
première fois de leur histoire de leur
longue histoire les restos du cœur nous
ont dit qu'ils allaient devoir refuser
de nouveaux bénéficiaires et diminuer la
quantité de nourriture délivrée pauvre
Coluche il doit se retourner dans sa
tombe comment en sommes-nous arrivés là
la 7è puissance du monde incapable
aujourd'hui de nourrir sa population
mais rassurez-vous quand même monsieur
le ministre tout ne va pas mal pour tout
le monde total continue d'engranger les
bénéfices et l'industrie agroalimentaire
s'en met plein les poches et pourtant
vous vous refusez de prendre l'argent là
où il est nous vous le disons très
clairement la situation est explosive
peut-être qu'il n'y aura pas de
révolution dans la rue mais vous serez
peut-être comptable d'une révolution
brune dans les urnes j'en viens à une
autre priorité la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et la
protection de la biodiversité le
diagnostic posé par la première ministre
en juin est parfait mais il nous faut là
aussi constater que les mesures
contenues dans ce budget ne sont pas à
la hauteur des enjeux et aux engagements
pris par le Président de la République 7
milliards supplémentaires sont inscrits
pour la transition écologique cet effort
est à saluer je le salue mais le compte
n'y est toujours pas on est encore très
loin des 33 milliards d'euros public de
dépenses publiques mentionné dans le
rapport que vous avez vous-même commandé
à jean-pisaniif ferry et Selma mafous
dans le détail 1,2 milliard d'euros est
consacré à la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments alors qu'il faudrait 3,3
milliards d'euros pour respecter chaque
année notre stratégie bas carbone 1,3
milliards pour le fond vert mais
celui-ci doit financer des projets de
rénovation énergétique de bâtiments mais
aussi des projets d'adaptation comme par
exemple la lutte contre contre les
incendies ou encore des projets liés à
la biodiversité
0,8 milliards flécher sur la transition
agricole et forestière mais on mélange
là aussi des mesures d'atténuation des
mesures d'adaptation ou de protection de
la biodiversité et que dire des des
crédits réservés aux mesures
agro-environnementales et climatique que
vous baissez dans ce budget pour éviter
ce saupoudrage qui nous rappelle d'aille
celui du plan de relance il aurait fallu
une planification des financements
écologiques avec des objectifs annuels
chiffrés par thématique et par
territoire nous nous permettant ensuite
une véritable évaluation et un véritable
contrôle du respect des objectifs nous
en sommes loin enfin je ne peux clore ce
chapitre sans évoquer l'amendement voté
en faveur des mobilités en Île-de-France
c'est une très bonne mesure que de
permettre la hausse du versement
mobilité tant les transp en commun ont
besoin de ressources mais que dire du
mépris affiché à l'égard de toutes les
autres régions de notre pays comme si
Marseille rouand Lyon Bordeaux mais
aussi des villes moyennes à l'image de
ryion n'avaient elles aussi pas besoin
de moyens colossaux pour développer les
transports en commun c'est une erreur
politique et justifier cette position en
en invoquant des territoires qui ne sont
pas prês et juste une vue de
l'esprit autre secteur autre crise le
logement depuis 2017 monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez cessé de faire des
économies sur le dos du logement les
résultats de cette politique sont
catastrophiques et pourtant vous
continuez à faire la sour d'oreille le
logement c'est le premier poste de
dépenses des ménage et ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux à peiner face à un coût
qui ne cesse d'augmenter les locataires
ont perdu l'équivalent d'un mois d'APL
par an et la réforme de leur mode de
calcul a fait 2 millions de perdants
entre de 2020 et
2021 parallèlement en ayant réalisé 6
milliards d'économies sur les bailleurs
sociaux depuis 2018 et malgré la
promesse d'un choc d'offre la production
de logements sociaux chute de manière
continue et la France compte aujourd'hui
400000 demandeurs de logement social de
plus qu'en
2017 toutes les semaines je reçois ma
permanence mais comme vous certainement
des ménages et des familles désemp
désemparées qui attendent d'un logement
depuis parfois des années ce n'est pas
tolérable et cette casse de la
construction ne se cantonne pas au
logement social puisque'au total 100000
logements privés de moins auront été
produits sur l'année écoulée par rapport
à 2017 la politique fiscale que vous
menez monsieur le ministre en favorisant
la location touristique au détriment du
logement péren a considérablement tendu
la situation dans les métropoles et les
communes littorales en disant le nombre
d'annonces sur la seule pl plateformme
d'Airbnb est passé de 30000 à
750000 pour redonner de la perspective
au ménages qui souhaitent accéder à la
propriété ou louer dans le parc privé ou
social il est urgent de stimuler la
production de logement et de remettre
des bien sur le marché locatif mais
malheureusement encore une fois ce
budget 2024 n'est pas à la hauteur
j'espère que vous saurez saisir
l'amendement transpartisan déposé
notamment par notre groupe par
Inaki
chanise dernier sujet qui figure
également très haut sur l'échelle des
priorités de nos concitoyens peut-être à
la première place la santé sur ce sujet
on pourrait dire la situation s'est
dégradée mais on ne pouvait pas prévoir
c'est faux les déserts médicaux avancent
au même rythme que la République recule
sur nos territoires alors oui vous avez
mis fin au numérus closusus c'est une
bonne chose la situation est-elle
meilleure aujourd'hui non elle continue
de se dégrader et les médecins de ville
manquent toujours comment accepter les
les ruptures d'approvisionnement de
médicaments les fermeture de lit dans
nos hôpitaux les lits dans les couloirs
de nos urgences quand celles-ci ne sont
tout simplement pas fermées si l'hôpital
va mal le secteur médical ne va pas bien
non plus vous le savez les conditions de
prise en charge de nos aînés que ce soit
à domicile en logement intermédiaire ou
en épade se dégrade alors certes des
facteurs conjoncturels ont encore
aggravé la crise structurelle qui frappe
ce secteur mais faut-il baisser les bras
non évidemment une enveloppe de 100
millions d'euros a été annoncé par la
première ministre à destination de
toutes les structures mais nous savons
vous comme moi que ce sera largement
insuffisant d'autant que les projection
démographiques sont connues et les
chiffres effrayants il faut dégager des
milliards supplémentaires pour prendre
en charge correctement les personnes
âgées aujourd'hui et celles en devenir
le rapport de Dominique libaau comme le
rapport de nos collègues Fiat ibora
disent tout ça très bien mais vous
refusez de voir la réalité en face et
tout comme vos prédécesseurs depuis plus
de 20 ans vous refusez la loi grand âge
tant attendue allez-vous pousser le
cynisme jusqu'à enterrer l'amendement
voté très largement en commission des
finances la semaine dernière qui prévoit
d'aider les résidents à payer leur note
d'hébergement devenu insupportable
allez-vous jeter à la poubelle cet
amendement au motif qu'il faut trouver
880 millions d'euros comment comprendre
qu'on donne 272 millions d'euros sous
forme de réduction d'impôts aux
résidents les plus aisés mais qu'on
refuse cette même aide aux résidents de
la classe moyenne qui peut comprendre
qu'on aide des millionnaires avec un
crédit d'impôt pour les petits travaux
de
jardinage pour plus de 800 millions
d'euros et que l'on refuse cette aide
fiscale aux résidents des pad aucune
justification ne serait
entendable répondre aux urgences demande
de l'argent supplémentaire et les
solutions existe dans ce budget vous
parvenez d'ailleurs péniblement à
appliquer des solutions que nous prenons
depuis des années après avoir répété à
l'envie que vous ne saviez pas définir
un super profit vous vous envisagez
enfin de taxer les infrastructures de
transport autoroute aéroport tout en
nous mettant d'ailleurs le transport
maritime alors même que la société CMA
CGM fait des profits
mirobolants mais pourquoi s'arrêter là
pour pourquoi ne pas taxer les super
profits les super dividendes quel que
soit le secteur est-il si difficile de
demander un effort exceptionnel
transitoire à ceux qui le peuvent
comment faire accepter des efforts à
tous les Français quand ceux qui
pourraient en faire sans dommage sont
laissés de côté pourquoi continuer ainsi
à préserver je dirais même à assister
une infime partie de nos concitoyens
ultra riche en les protégeant à tout
prix de l'impôt et en refusant de les
faire cont buer à hauteur de leurs
moyens des propositions d'économie
monsieur le ministre nous en avons fait
à l'appel cela fait des années que nous
vous interpellons interpellons pardon
sur les niches fiscales et sociales qui
privent le budget de ressources
indispensa pour financer les priorités
que je viens d'évoquer encore
faudrait-il nous entendre comment
accepter par exemple que vous refusie de
plafonner le crédit d'impôtrecherche
alors que les dépenses qui sont liées
sont passées en 8 ans 8 ans mes chers
collègues de 2 milliards à plus de 7
milliards et au budget 2024 ce sont même
8 milliards qu'ils sont affichés alors
que les résultats ne sont pas au
rendez-vous dans certaines entreprises
et ce n'est pas moi qui le dit les
rapports vous embarrassent tant tant ils
se multiplient et disent tous la même
chose France stratégie court des comptes
Conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
RALP mais par idéologie vous niz
l'évidence selon un autre rapport publié
hier par le comité d'évaluation des
réformes de la fiscalité du capital si
l'ISF avait avait été maintenu il aurait
rapporté en 2022 6,3 milliards d'euros
or l'IFI a rapporté seulement 1,8
milliards l'an dernier soit un manque à
gagné de plus de 4 milliards d'euros
pour les caisses de l'État alors
monsieur le ministre je vous le dis
l'entreprise est là pour créer de la
richesse l'État est là pour créer de la
justice
alors sans surprise vous l'aurez compris
nous ne voterons pas votre budget
monsieur le ministre synonyme pour
beaucoup de français appartenant aux
classes populaires aux classes moyennes
des fors surdimensionné alors qu'en même
temps vous poursuivez une politique
favorable non pas aux riches mais aux
ultra riches c'est-à-dire à une toute
toute toute petite poignée de
contribuable votre budget c'est mission
impossible vous vous êtes enferré dans
une double contrainte insoluble vous
prétendez réduire le défic cite à 4,4 %
sans lever de nouvelles recettes
fiscales il en résulte des coupes
criminelles en matière de santé par
exemple ou la progression de longâ au
regard de l'inflation prévue mais
surtout des besoins croissants relèvent
bien d'une austérité l'obstination à
vouloir réduire les prélèvements
obligatoires dans le contexte actuel est
idéologique et irresponsable car si nous
pouvons toujours discuter avec le FMI
avec Bruxelles avec les banques
centrales une chose est certaine c'est
que nous ne pourrons pas discuter avec
la planète alors je vous le dis assumez
que la cohésion de la nation est plus
est plus importante que tout le reste je
vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à madame Lise
manier pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
horizon
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
du budget monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues après les plus de 30h consacré
en commission des finances sur la
première partie du projet de budget de
l'État pour 2024 il nous appartient
désormais d'en débattre dans notre
hémicycle et à mon tour je veux
remercier très sincèrement le rapporteur
général du budget et le président de la
commission des finances qui nous ont
permis tout au long de la semaine
dernière d'avoir de vrais débats
respectueux et de fond en commission
c'est un exercice démocratique important
et qui nous honore je dois quand même
vous dire aussi mon regret d'avoir vu la
première partie rejetée par notre
commission des finances et ne pas avoir
toujours compris le positionnement des
oppositions sur certains points
typiquement et pour n'en citer qu'un le
rejet de l'article 32 qui fixe les
relations financière entre l'État et la
sécurité sociale nous semble assez
incompréhensible
le débat s'ouvre donc désormais dans
notre hémicycle et il me paraît
important de repartir de la base le
contexte économique avec une inflation
majeure et des taux d'intérêt élevés
n'empêche pas notre pays de poursuivre
sa bonne marche économique avec un taux
de chômage nettement amélioré et des
emplois créés toujours plus nombreux il
nous faut donc clairement continuer
notre choix de politique économique et
maintenir cette confiance pour nos
entreprise et nos emplois et créer de la
valeur car pour partager de la valeur
encore faut-il en créer le contexte
géopolitique particulièrement douloureux
vient lui aussi confirmer les choix qui
sont ceux du gouvernement et de notre
majorité le renforcement des missions
régaliennes de l'État avec des efforts
massifs pour notre sécurité nos armées
et notre école enfin le contexte
climatique et environnemental nous
oblige à accélérer massivement notre
transition ou plutôt nos transitions et
par un effort inédit de 7 milliards
d'euros supplémentair consacré dans ce
projet de loi de finan 2024 nous sommes
clairement au
rendez-vous ces trois grands enjeux
étant opposé je vais en rajouter un 4è
celui de notre pacte républicain ce
pacte républicain c'est ce qui nous
permet de faire nation en offrant à
chaque citoyen français la capacité à
comprendre sa place dans notre société
et a déterminé son rôle individuel pour
notre fonctionnement
collectif cela nécessite que nous
responsabl politiqu que l'on soit élus
locaux parlementaires ou membres du
gouvernement nous soyons absolument
vigilant sur la question qui traverse
l'ensemble de notre société celle de la
justice fiscale et sociale et je veux
commencer par dire à chaque citoyen
français que notre système est
aujourd'hui le le système le plus juste
car le plus redistributif du monde cela
veut simplement dire que la contribution
des plus aisés vient répondre
positivement aux besoins des moins aisés
les 2 tiers des français reçoivent en
moyenne davantage en prestation et en
services publics qu'il ne versent en
impôt taxes et contribution sociales et
je formule ici la demande du groupe
horizon monsieur le ministre des comptes
publices pourrait-on adresser à chaque
foyer fiscal
la réalité de son apport à la nation et
la réalité de ce que la nation lui
apporte c'est une pédagogie que nous
devons impérativement reconstruire et
qui mérite je le crois un nouvel effort
la justice fiscale et sociale elle doit
s'incarner dans l'ensemble de nos choix
et de nos décisions les bons résultats
économiques la création d'emploi et de
valeur la baisse du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi doivent permettre à chaque
Français de vivre dignement de son
travail et tenir la promesse d'une
amélioration du niveau de vie de chaque
travailleur tout au long de sa carrière
la conférence sociale sur les salaires
en cela est une démarche qu'il faut
encourager et qui doit déboucher sur des
mesures concrètes soutenir l'emploi et
le travail c'est aussi baisser les
impositions qui pèsent sur les salaires
les impôts sur les ménages ont baissé
massivement depuis 2017 et nous devons
poursuivre dans cette voie fidèlement
aux eng du président de la
République depuis presque 2 ans
maintenant nous vivons dans un contexte
d'inflation qui a bousculer nos
habitudes ce niveau d'inflation a été
particulièrement maîtrisé par les
décisions que vous avez porté monsieur
le ministre pour en limiter les impacts
mais pour un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens l'impact sur la vie
quotidienne est bien plus important que
pour d'autres notre groupe horizon et
apparenté soutient donc une
revalorisation uniforme pour tous les
franç frais les pensions de base des
retraites seront revalorisées de 5,2 %
cont tenu de la règle d'automaticité
fixée appliquons donc ce même taux de
revalorisation pour les tranches
d'impôts sur le revenu revaloriser les
tranches d'impôts sur le revenu à 4,8
pourrait donner le sentiment qu'il y a
une inflation différenciée d'un Français
à l'autre alors que ce n'est pas le cas
et alors même qu'un grand nombre de
secteurs professionnels ont fait un réel
effort de revalor
des
salaires de la même façon par souci de
justice nous proposerons en deuxème
partie d'ouvrir l'indemnité carburant
travailleur jusqu'au 7e décile pour
permettre aux classes moyennes qui
travaillent d'en bénéficier et enfin
pour que le travail paye nous
proposerons le déblocage exceptionnel de
l'épargne salariale en 2024 comme nous
l'avions fait avec la loi pouvoir
d'achat en 2022 et alors que le contexte
économique est similaire
la justice fiscale et sociale c'est
aussi l'imposition de tous et je veux
saluer monsieur le ministre votre combat
remporté sur l'imposition minimale des
grandes entreprises internationales
c'est une réelle avancée qui nous permet
d'ouvrir les prochaines étape avec la
question de l'imposition minimum des
personnes physiques et nous porterons un
amendement d'appel sur ce sujet majeur
dans ce souci de justice fiscale nous
porterons également la prolongation de
la contribution sur la rente des
produits producteur d'électricité pour
l'année 2024 avec des paramètres
renouvelés pour ne pas mettre en
difficulté certains des acteurs
concernés la justice fiscale c'est aussi
ne pas exclure ceux qui ont besoin de
dispositifs de soutien le prê àau zé est
un formidable outil de soutien au ménag
pour l'acquisition de leur habitation
nous portons donc avec conviction la
nécessité d'élargir les critères de
ressources de plafond et d'éligibilité
territoriale d'accès au pré àau zéro
l'économie du bâtiment et du Logement
les difficultés d'accès à la propriété
et le renchérissement des coouts
d'emprunt doivent nous convaincre de
soutenir les ménages modestes qui
souhaitent acquérir leurs bien et la
justice fiscale et sociale s'incarne
aussi par la lutte sans faille contre la
fraude ce projet de loi de finance 2024
vient y répondre et veille même à la
renforcer par un plan de lutte contre la
fraude ferme et Ambit que vous portez
monsieur le ministre et que nous
saluons la justice fiscale et sociale
c'est aussi veillé à l'impact de nos
outils fiscaux et budgétaires et en ce
sens le budget vert de l'État que nous
souhaitons voir ouvrir aux collectivités
territoriales est un réel outil d'aide à
la décision monsieur le ministre je
tiens à souligner votre engagement pour
que les trajectoires de verdissement de
nos outils fiscaux soi conçu en lien
avec les acteurs concernés c'est un gage
de réussite et d'acceptabilité absolue
ces transitions doivent être
accompagnées nous le savons et c'est
pourquoi il nous semble impératif de
soutenir les investissement nécessaires
réaliser par les entreprises et
notamment par des dispositifs de
suramortissement et de prime à la
conversion afin d' d'atténuer les coûts
souvent plus élevés pour les machines et
les engins fonctionnant aux énergies les
moins polluantes bien sûr il nous faut
aussi et surtout je crois rappeler aux
Français que l'État ne peut peut pas
tout et ne doit pas tout s'il était
parfaitement légitime et indispensable
que l'État protège les Français et
l'économie française dans le cadre des
crises majeures qui se sont superposées
les unes aux autres il nous faut aussi
savoir retrouver un niveau
d'intervention normal la remontée
importante des taux d'intérêt vient
engloutir des dizaines de milliards
d'euros dans la charge de la dette
autant d'argent public que nous ne
pouvons donc investir dans des
politiques publiques qui qui en ont
besoin la trajectoire de redressement
des finances publiques doit donc
impérativement être tenue c'est là un
impératif de
souveraineté et c'est aussi parce que
l'État ne peut pas tout et ne doit pas
tout que nous soutiendrons des
amendements redonnant des capacités
d'action aux élus locaux notamment sur
leur taux d'impôt locaux d'exonération
ou de surimposition l'État et les
collectivités territoriales doivent agir
main dans la main mais il faut faire
confiance aux élus locaux qui sont des
acteur majeur de l'aménagement du
territoire et de la lutte contre les
fractures territoriales et ce c'est ce
sur quoi nous nous engageons voilà en
quelques mots mes chers collègues les
analyses et axes de travail de notre
groupe horizon et apparenté sur ce
projet de loi de finance 2024 évidemment
notre groupe sera mobilisé au côté du
gouvernement pour enrichir ce texte et
permettre à notre pays de se doter d'un
budget crédible et utile à nos
concitoyens en sétant troublés je vous
remercie
je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame
Christine Hari pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
écologiste
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur général qui n'est pas là il
est là monsieur le président de la
commission des finances il est jamais là
où on pense qu'il doit être hein voilà
monsieur le ministre mes chers chers
collègues le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 intervient dans un contexte de
forts besoins écologiques et sociaux
dans votre dossier de presse vous
précisez qu'il vise à répondre au défis
de demain l'été 2023 se classe au 4e r
des plus chaud en France sur l'ensemble
de la saison la température moyenne de
21,8 est supérieure à la normale que
notre pays a connu entre 91 et 2020 deux
épisodes caniculaires ont abouti à une
une vigilance rouge météoance a dénombré
au cours de cet été 26 vigilances rouges
et
oranges partout dans le monde les
phénomènes climatiques extrêmes se sont
multipliés en Grèce et au Canada pour ne
citer que ces exemples le secrétaire
général de l'ONU Antonio goutarz a
déclaré qu'il y a à peu près un plus
d'un mois que l'effondrement climatique
a commencé l'Observatoire européen
Copernicus a également annoncé que
compte tenu de la canicule océanique il
é est probable que 2023 soit l'année la
plus chaude que l'humanité est connue et
pendant ce temps en juillet dernier une
étude de l'INC indiquait que 9 millions
de Français 9 millions de Français
étaient en situation de privation
matérielle et sociale en 2022 et les
besoins en logements sociaux sont
estimés à
518000 logements par an selon l'Union
social pour l'habitat le nombre de
personnes pauvres et de travailleurs
pauvres explose
je m'arrête là vous conviendrez donc
avec moi qu'il y a urgence et que plutôt
que de répondre au défis de demain il
faut plutôt relever les défis dès
aujourd'hui car faire face à nos
engagements de réduction des gaz des
émission de gaz à effet de serre à
l'horizon 2030 et réussir la transition
écologique dans le délai imparti pour
cela des moyens supplémentaires doivent
être mobilisés et ils sont conséquents
le rapport mafous et pisanif les estime
à 34 milliards d'euros pour
2024 le projet de loi de finances pour
2024 présente 491 milliards d'euros de
dépenses 9 milliards de moins qu'en 2023
et 349 milliards d'euros de recett c'est
donc un déficit de 142 milliards d'euros
déficit que l'on pourrait réduire si le
volet recette de ce budget intégré
toutes on peut rêver ou des propositions
raisonnables de recettes qui sont sont
faites ça et là y compris dans les
proches de la
majorité je pense à l'impôt exceptionnel
sur le patrimoine financier bien sûr des
plus aisés proposés par Selma mafou et
Pisan Ferri qui pourrait rapporter 5
milliards d'euros dès l'année 2024 je
pense aux propositions de nos collègues
matthi et sensu dans le rapport de la
fiscalité du patrimoine et plus
précisément aux mesures visant à
accroître la contribution des revenus du
capital au redressement des finances
publiques à travers une hausse modéré on
retrouve là bien jeanpa matthi de trois
points du taux de prélèvement
forfaitaire unique àè à faire mieux
contribuer le patrimoine financier
conservé dans des holdings patrimonials
en relevant les différentes côtes part
pour frais et charges applicaablees au
remonté de dividendes et au plus-valu de
session de participation peuvent s'y
ajouter la juste taxation des super
profits réalisés les super dividendes
versé ces dernières années par plusieurs
entreprises dans différents secteurs
maritime agroalimentaire pharmaceutique
que nous proposons depuis l'an dernier
peuvent s'y ajouter la suppression de
niches fiscales onéreus et injustifié
teles que la taxe au tonnage dans le
secteur maritime qui n'a plus de raison
d'être et qui a coûté en cumulé sur les
années 2021 et 2022 4,2 milliards
d'euros finances publiques peuvent s'y
ajouter l'augmentation du vm à un niveau
national pour financer les transports de
proximité qui sont utiles socialement et
qui sont utiles écologiquement peuvent
s'y ajouter la fin de la fiscalité
avantageuse dont bénéficie le secteur
aérien à travers le taux réduit de TVA
et l'absence de taxation du kérosè nous
proposons pour cela une TVA autonormale
sur les vols intérieurs à l'exception
des vols à destination et en provenance
des territoires d'outrem de la Corse un
d'entre vous l'a proposé également
rejeté la mise en place d'une
écoontribution sur les billets d'avion
pouvant générer 3 milliards d'euros par
an selon les travaux de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat autant de
recettes qui permettrai de diminuer la
dette publique mais aussi sa charge en
ces moments où les engagements
financiers de l'État repartent à la
hausse et talonnent le budget de
l'Éducation nationale nous y reviendrons
lors du débat sur la dette publique car
chers collègues Monsieur le Maire a lors
de sa prise de parole vanté les effets
positifs de sa politique de l'offre
depuis
2017 il me semble juste de rappeler le
coût de certaines de ces dispositions et
de ces dispositifs pour les finances
publiques lors du précédent quinquena
baisse du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés une politique qui se situe à
contre-courant des décisions prises par
le Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis elle a
coûté 11 milliards d'euros aux finances
publiques remplacement de l'impôt sur
les de solidarité sur la fortune par
l'IFI cette mesure a coûté en cumulé
15,5 milliards d'euros aux finances
publiques création du prélèvement
forfaitaire unique cette mesure a coûté
entre 5,5 et 9 milliards d'euros aux
finances publiques baisse des impôts de
production coût estimé pour les finances
publiques 25,83 milliards d'euros sans
prétendre à l'exhaustivité dans le
recensement des différents positifs
dispositifs que vous avez mis en place
on observe un manque à gagner qui osyle
entre 57 et 62 milliards d'euros c'est
autant de recettes en moins pour
financer la transition écologique les
services publics le logement social mais
c'est vos choix politiques son ce ne
sont pas les nôtres venons-en la
compétitivité verte terminologie qui
rejoint la grande liste des expressions
qui sonne creux et qui refuse
d'interroger la pertinence de votre nove
langue économie verte croissance verte
et autres l'article 5 du projet de loi
crée le crédit d'impôt au titre des
investissements en faveur de l'industrie
verte aucune garantie sociale et
environnementale n'est demandée aux
entreprises qui en bénéficieront au
titre de leur investissements alors même
que la question de la conditionnalité
sociale et environnementale des aides
publiques est
prignante ce dispositif doit être
renforcé car maintenant que vous vous
êtes enfin rendu compte de l'importance
de relocaliser les industries en France
il faut encadrer les soutiens publics
pour éviter des effets d'obè comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui pour d'autres
dépenses fiscales comme par exemple le
Crédit Impôt Recherche utile en son
principe mais qui doit être réformé il
faut en ce sens rallonger à 5 ans la
durée d'exploitation sur le territoire
pour éviter les délocalisations au bout
de 2 ans dans des pays où la main
d'œuvre est moins coûteuse il faut
conditionner ce crédit d'impôt à des
obligations environnementales alignées
avec no objectifs je pense notamment à
l'accord de Paris à la stratégie
nationale bas carbone nous avons fait
des propositions en ce sens en
commission des finances nous espérons
nous souhaitons elle ne devrait pas être
baliée avec le
493 quelques mots également sur le plan
épargne avenir climat auquel notre
groupe s'était déjà opposé lors de
l'examen de la projet de du projet de
loi industrie au-delà de la cble ce
dispositif essentiellement des mineurs
le montant des encours mobilisables
reste faible du fait de la petite
capacité d'épargne de cette catégorie
d'âge de population sauf celle dont les
parents disposent de moyens relativement
importants or le plan d'éparne avenir
climat n'offre à ce stade aucune
garantie aucune garantie de la bonne
allocation des en cours au profit de la
transition écologique nous n'avons en
particulier aucune assurance que
l'argent épargné au nom de l'avenir du
climat ne financera pas des entreprises
destructrices du climat et donc de
l'avenir la mobilisation de l'épargne
doit prioritairement porter sur le
fléchage des en courours issu de
l'épargne salariale de l'assurance vie
et des divers livrés réglementés grâce à
une refonte des règles qui s'y
appliquent notamment en terme de
fiscalité et de garantie s'agissant des
transports je ne métal rpasse sur les
services express régionaux
métropolitains pour lesquels vous avez
annoncé une Vale de milliards et don
nous attendons toujours la traduction
concrète dans ce budget 2024 sur les 100
milliards annoncés par madame la
Première ministre il y a déjà presque 1
an il n'y a à ce stade que 765 millions
d'euros pour la phase d'étude dans le
cadre des contrats plans État-Région en
cours de négociation pour 5 ans sans
garantie de financement supplémentaire
de l'État en fonction de la maturité des
projets lorsqu'il seront labellisés
aucun engagement n'a été pris en ce sens
des effets d'annonce aussi sur le
passeril à 49 € prévu selon les rapports
du ministre du Transport pour l'été 2024
or tout porte à croire qu'il y a là une
approche en silo sans concertation avec
les élus locaux et quand je dis tout
porte à croire je suis assuré de ce que
il n'y a pas eu de concertation pour la
mise en œuvre dans des délais annoncés
de cette mesure pourtant nécessaire là
encore il faudra préciser clairement la
contribution de l'État laquelle ne doit
doit pas fonction ponctionner les
ressources nécessaires au développement
à la rénovation des trains inter cités
et du réseau enfin pour nos
collectivités racine de la République le
compte NZ pas d'abord la hausse de 220
millions d'euros de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement inscrite dans ce
projet de loi ne couvre que 0,8 % de
l'inflation l'indexation de cette
dotation sur l'inflation est une demande
juste qui permettra de préserver le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'action et
d'achat des collectivités territoriales
si l'on est é lgit le bilan à l'ensemble
des concours financiers à loués aux
collectivités en 2024 cela équivaut à
une perte de ressources de plus de 2,2
milliards d'euros inflation comprise
pour les collectivités territoriales ce
montant inclut des effets de la fin des
dispositifs de protection des
collectivités contre la hausse des prix
de l'énergie qui sont estimées à 1,1
milliard d'euros votre décision
d'arrêter les soutiens de l'État aux
collectivités sur la base d'une baisse
globale des prix de l'énergie est très
discutable puisque plusieurs
collectivités ont été obligés de signer
des contrats triénaux à des prix élevés
ne bénéficient pas encore de la
répercussion de la baisse des tarifs
autre point noir de ce projet de loi
pour les collectivités c'est la ponction
à hauteur de 67 millions d'euros d'un
ensemble de dotations et de compensation
d'exonération en 2024 cela représente 27
millions d'euros en moins pour le bloc
communal 10 millions d'euros en moins
pour les départements et 30 millions
d'euros en moins pour les régions il
s'agit là d'un sacré coup de Rabou vous
ne prévoyez rien non plus pour compenser
votre décision unilatérale de
revalorisation de 1,5 de la valeur du
point d'indice de la fonction publique
depuis le 1er juillet 2023 qui s'impose
aux collectivités après une précédente
hausse déjà non compensée une bonne
nouvelle tout de même qu'il faut
attribuer avant tout aux élus locaux qui
en ont fait la demande depuis des années
c'est la prise en compte à partir de
2024 des aménagement de terrain pour le
calcul du fond de compensation pour la
TVA et une autre bonne nouvelle c'est
votre renoncement à la suppression de la
deuxème partie de la CVAE et pourtant
nous vous avions alerté l'an dernier sur
la nocivité de cette mesure je le disais
dans mon propre introductif vous
communiquez et d'ailleurs plutôt assez
bien puisque vous saturez les médias sur
l'ensemble des projets que vous avez
mais la preuve ce projet de budget 2024
s'intitule répondre au défis de demain
et il est de notre devoir d'analyser
votre communication et vos actes avec
seul d'analyse les besoins des
Françaises et des Français et leur
traduction dans le PLF
2024 le résultat est hélas
insatisfaisant et votre politique
monsieur le ministre déplaît y compris
dans votre propre camp puisque nous
avons voté et adopté en commission des
finances des amendements proposés par
les vôtres cette opposition manifeste à
votre orientation en matière budgétaire
nous a conduit à rejeter mardi soir
l'article liminaire de ce texte qui
résume la trajectoire de redressement
des finances publiques à l'horizon 2027
et vendredi dernier la toute première
partie de votre texte car il ne répond
pas aux besoins légitimes exprimés par
nos concitoyens donc à situation
inchangé bien entendu le groupe
écologiste maintiendra les position
exprimé en commission des finances pour
relever les défis d'aujourd'hui sans
attendre ceux de demain je vous remercie
je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc
Tellier pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général chers
collègu hier s'est ouverte la conférence
sociale sur les salaires à cette
occasion vous avez affirmé monsieur le
ministre je cite que vous étiez contre
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation contre la hausse généralisée
des salaires et opposé à un coup de
pouce du smille c'est donc une
conférence sur les bas salaires non pour
les augmenter mais pour qu'ils reste bas
êtes-vous à ce point déconnecté monsieur
le ministre du portefeuille des franç
à la lecture de ce projet de loi de
finances tout porte à le croire rien
ou si peu pour les français concernant
leur pouvoir de vivre rien sur le prix
des denrées alimentaires rien sur le
prix de l'essence rien sur le prix de
l'énergie depuis 2017 vous êtes sourd à
la situation sociale du pays depuis 2017
votre seule boussole a été la politique
de de l'offre la théorie du
ruissellement des riches vers les
couches moyennes et modestes qui est à
l'œuvre selon la Dache quand les gros
maigrissent les maigres meurent mais
c'est une hérésie toutes les études
montre que l'accroissement des
patrimoines des ultrares
1170 milliards d'euros en 2022 pour les
500 plus grandes fortunes s'accompagne
d'un taux de pauvreté qui progresse
face à ce constat pourtant
inéductable les libéraux ressortent le
sitnel record d'Europe du taux du
prélèvement
obligatoire mais pourquoi est-il si
élevé tout simplement parce qu'il a fait
le choix des services collectifs pour
répondre au défis avec la création et
l'extension de la sécurité sociale avec
la maîtrise des grands services publics
avec le développement des collectivités
territoriales porteuses de servicees de
proximité notre pays a donc fait le
choix de mettre du commun là oou d'autre
choisissez de privilégier des réponses
individuelles au défis en matière de
santé d'éducation de Sécurité de
Transport c'est ce modèle qui est au
cœur de la confrontation engagée depuis
des décennies et qui s'aiguise dans ce
PLF pour 2020 2 plus précisément
C comment allons-nous répondre à la
nécessaire augmentation des salaires des
pensions des allocations comment
allons-nous affronter une crise du
logement qui s'intensifie comment
allons-nous réussir la transition
écologique et répondre à l'urgence
climatique comment allons-nous permettre
aux collectivités locales
d'assurer leur rôle de premier maillon
de la République si le taux de
prélèvement est si élevé c'est aussi
parce qu'on ont été multipliés les
cadeaux fiscaux plus de 175 milliards
d'euros qui profite à une minorité plus
le taux de
prélèvement plus que le taux de
prélèvement c'est aujourd'hui la forme
des prélèvements qu'il faut regarder
aujourd'hui forcé de constater qu'ils
sont de plus en plus régressifs
et
ça c'est le vrai drame en ayant fait de
la TVA l'impôt le plus important en
ayant supprimé les impôts sur le
patrimoine qui touchait les haut de la
distribution en ayant multiplié
exonération et allègement sur un petit
nombre de ménages et d'entreprises vous
aait rendu les prélèvements obligatoires
de notre pays régressive nous éloignant
du sens de l'article 13 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui dispose qu'une contribution
commune et indispensable et qu'elle doit
être également répartie entre tous les
citoyens en raison de leur faculté
l'impôt sur le revenu le seul progressif
aujourd'hui ne représente plus que 20 %
des recettes fiscal soit 54 % de moins
que la TVA et même 30 % de moins que la
CSG c'est bien trop peu les citoyens de
ce pays ne sont pas des clients ils
n'ont pas à en avoir pour leur impôts
comme l'avait dit Gabriel
attaque non l'impôt doit redevenir un
outil au service de la réduction des
inégalités mais aussi un moyen
proportionnel au moyen de chacun pour le
financement de nos services publics et
de notre modèle social car c'est bien de
ça qu'il s'agit les défis sont immenses
et il faut nous donner collectivement
les moyens d'y répondre réorienter une
part des dépenses fiscales ou des
allégements sociaux permettrai de créer
un véritable plan d'urgence pour
l'hôpital faire contribuer les
patrimoines les plus importants par la
création d'un ISF rénové qui intégrerait
bien mobiliers bien professionnel bien
immobilier permettrait de dégager des
ressources pour assurer le financement
de la transition écologique mobiliser
les pares populaire dans des projets
d'avenir indépendance énergétique
infrastructure ferroviaire pour le fret
et les voyageurs pôle public du
médicament et également une voie à
développer conditionner les aides aux
entreprises constitue un autre levier
qui doit plus que jamais être exploité
quand celle-ci représente près d'un
tiers du budget de l'État soit 200
milliards d'euros une étude publiée par
l'Institut de recherche économique et
sociale posa quatre questions au sujet
de ces aides publiques
combi pourquoi pour quel effet et à
quelles condition c'est ces questions
qui devrait guider l'octroi des aides
publiques les 22 milliards d'euros du
cice ont-ils permis de créer des emplois
non ils ont surtout accru les marges des
entreprises les 7 milliards d'euros du
CIR ont-ils contribué de manière
significative à la hausse des dépenses
de recherche et de développement depuis
sa mise en place non toujours non tout
cela doit changer enfin la poporisation
de notre population n'est pas sans lien
avec la dégradation des services publics
les deux qui reviennent le plus dans la
bouche de nos concitoyens étant
l'hôpital public et l'école sur
l'hôpital public qui subit année après
année une situation de plus en plus
alarmante fermeture de lit
épuisement généralisé des soignants
impossibilité d'accès aux soins
dégradation de la Santé de la population
et malgré ça l'odam fixé à 3,2 % se
situera pour l'année 2024 en dessus en
dessous de l'inflation et en dessous de
sa dynamique naturelle d'augmentation de
4,6 %. enfin l'école reste elle aussi
malade il manque en moyenne au moins un
enseignant dans 48 % des collèges et des
lycées de France où les salaires des
enseignants a chuté depuis les années 80
où l'origine sociale des élèves pèse
toujours énormément sur les résultats où
les compétences des parents et les
conditions de logement influe sur la
réussite de nos enfants c'est là qu'il
faut consacrer des moyens humains et
financiers c'est quelques exemples
suffisent à rappeler que le budget 2024
répond à des choix et non à des besoins
le budget 2024 ne répondra pas à ces
enjeux forceé de constater qu'il n'y a
pas de majorité en accord avec la teneur
du texte proposé la discussion en
commission ainsi que le vote sanction
par lequel elle s'est terminé l'ont
démontré nous connaissons donc l'issue
de cette séquence un 493 qui viendra une
nouvelle fois empêcher notre assemblée
de se faire de faire évoluer ce texte et
de se prononcer une fois encore le
Parlement sera muselé et la blessure
démocratique béante
elle le sera d'autant plus si vous
faites le choix cette année encore de
vous Assir purement et simplement sur
les débats qui ont eu lieu en commission
et les amendements qui ont été adoptés
certains d'ailleurs à l'initiative de
vos alliés la taxe sur la sur les super
dividendes un barè de l'impôt sur le
revenu plus juste ou encore la hausse de
la TTF sont autant de mesures de justice
fiscale qui trouvent un écho important
dans notre pays et qu'il faut
nécessairement entendre ne pas laisser
la possibilité de voter ce budget ou
conserver le texte sans les évolutions
voté en commission ce n'est pas laisser
la possibilité de faire d'autres choix
pour la vie des Français les députés du
groupe GDR se battront pied à pied pour
que les enjeux humains collectifs et de
solidarité
prévalent
mercio à Madame Émilie Bonivard pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
budget après budget nous alertons le
gouvernement sur la situation financière
de notre pays et ses conséquences sur
les Français explosion de la dette 45000
€ par français et de ses intérêts la
France championne européenne des taxes
et impôts une dépense publique qui
augmente alors que nos concitoyens
voient chaque jour le service public qui
leur est réellement utile se dégrader je
pense évidemment à la santé au soutien
aux personnes âgées dépendantes à
l'école à la sécurité voilà votre bilan
malheureusement en matière budgétaire
mais quelles conséquences concrètes
aujourd'hui pour les Français notamment
pour ceux qui travaillent dur qui se
lève tous les matins qui contribuent
largement à la solidarité nationale et
n'ont jamais droit à rien je veux parler
des classes moyennes chez les
républicains notre projet est
radicalement différent supprimer le
gaspillage d'argent public réellement
avec volontarisme et la dépense publique
non efficiente pour baisser les impôts
et soutenir un service public réellement
utile au français stop à tout ce qui
relève de la bureaucratie dévorante
coûteuse inutile stop aussi aux aides
sans contrepartie ma collègue louvagie
en a parlé tout à l'heure aujourd'hui
concrètement les Français font face à
une explosion du coût du logement une
explosion des prix des carburants une
perte de pouvoir d'achat pour les
familles il n'arrivve plus à faire face
or rien dans ce budget ne répond à cette
crise rien sur l'accès au logement tout
d'abord il s'agit du premier poste de
dépenses des ménages nous faisons face
aujourd'hui à une hausse massive des
taux d'intérêt une hausse des loyers une
chute de la construction et un logement
social totalement débordé c'est une
grave crise sociale qui se
profile si la conjoncture inflationniste
explique en partie cette crise la
politique largement désincitative du
président de la République en matière
d'immobilier depuis 6 ans y est pour
beaucoup il y a une conviction assez
incompréhensible du côté de la majorité
que l'argent investi dans la pierre
c'est de l'argent qui dort au service
d'une cause désuettes une France des
propriétaires or loin d'être désuettes
cette cause reste au cœur des projets de
de vie de nos concitoyens que nous
devons
accompagner les conséquences de ces
choix anti-immobiliers sont aujourd'hui
une incapacité réelle pour nos jeunes à
se loger une explosion des loyers et
charges une impossibilité à devenir
propriétaire en 20 ans hors inflation le
prix des logements a augmenté de 88 % il
est impossible pour nos jeunes
aujourd'hui de devenir propriétaires
sans par parler de la crise majeure que
va subir toute la filière du BTP et ses
emplois la rénovation énergétique ne
suffira pas à essuyer les plâtres avec
les républicains nous proposons à
contrario de renforcer le prêt à tau
zéro pour n nos jeunes là où vous le
rétrécissez de réduire la fiscalité des
donations non seulement entre parents et
enfants mais aussi entre grands-parents
et petits enfants pour débloquer
l'épargne pour que les jeunes puissent
plus facilement accéder à la propriété
un Mor sur le zan qui rarifie encore
plus le foncier la construction et
contribuera à l'inflation des coûts du
foncier une révision juste de la
fiscalité Airbnb la restauration d'un
crédit d'impôt sur les intérêts
d'emprunt un crédit d'impôt simple pour
la rénovation énergétique et non pas
l'usine à gaz de ma prime renove ces
choix les républicains les financent
ourours par des économies précises et
renseigné comme l'a évoqué ma
collègue madame la députée je perds de
l'argent chaque fois que que je vais
travailler voilà ce que me disent mes
concitoyens qui n'ont d'autre choix que
de se déplacer en voiture et ce n'est
pas un chèque dérisoire de 100 € ciblé
sur une fraction de Français qui
résoudra le problème le prix du
carburant est constitué de plus de
moitié de taxes sur 2 € le litre de
gazol plus d'un € est récolté par les
caisses de l'État les cas encaissent
donc 40 milliards d'euros de taxes sur
les carburants avec les républicain nous
demandons qu'une partie de cet argent
soit rendu aux Français aujourd'hui avec
une baisse immédiate de la titicpe
permettant une économie de 12,5 centimes
d'euros par litre pour tous pour un coût
de 5 milliards j'ajoute que cetteesure
cette mesure n'a rien
d'antienvironnemental car nous pourrions
mettre aussi en place une taxe élastique
encore moins coûteuse lorsque le prix du
baril monte la taxe baisse et lorsque le
baril baisse elle monte avec un plafond
c'est le prix à la pompe chers collègues
qui encourage la transition écologique
pas le montant de la taxe étouffer
fiscalement les Français ne servira en
rien la transition écologique enfin je
souhaite terminer sur la nécessaire
correction d'une politique familiale
injuste initiée par François Hollande
jamais remise en cause par le président
Macron la baisse du cotient familial
impactant les classes moyennes et la fin
de l'Université des de des allocation
familiale c'est des augmentations
d'impôts pour les familles et une baisse
de leur allocation familiale nous
proposons avec les républicains
d'augmenter ce quotient à
2750 €. monsieur le ministre je ne doute
pas malheureusement qu'il y aura un 393
mais je souhaite impérativement que vous
continuez la défiscalisation sur les
pourboire je n'ai pas pu en parler en
commission et il est impératif que cet
élément soit dans le texte final pour le
pouvoir d'achat de tous les travailleurs
de la
restaur la parole est à Madame Marina
Ferrari pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
démocrate
présidente merci
beaucoup madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues l'examen d'un projet de loi de
finance est l'occasion de se poser un
certain nombre de questions dont
certaines revêent un caractère
particulièrement sensible telle est la
politique du logement qui mobilise part
qui mobilise près de 40 milliards
d'euros dont 15 milliards de dépenses
fiscales et qui de la vie de tous ici ne
produit pas de résultats probants le
logement joue un rôle premier dans la
vie des ménages premier poste de dépense
a été rappelé mais également le logement
est une des principales est un pardon
est le principal sujet de préoccupation
des Français lieu d'habitation lieu de
famille parfois héritage le logement
représente souvent les économies de
toute une vie et une forme d'assurance
pour le futur pour ceux qui ont la
possibilité d'accéder à la propriété or
le constat est clair notre pays traverse
une crise du du logement sans précédent
à la crise larvé déjà ancienne s'est
additionné une crise du logement depuis
un an et demi et c'est une crise
conjoncturelle avec la forte hausse des
taux d'intérêt l'inflation l'explosion
des coûts de la construction et la
raréfaction et l'augmentation du prix du
foncier notre réponse ne peut être que
fiscale nous ne réglerons pas tout en
revoyant la fiscalité des locations de
courte durée ou en adaptant une nouvelle
fois la TVA sur la construction des
logements sociaux nous sommes convaincus
que nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
d'une grande loi
que les députés démocrates appellent de
leur vœux depuis plusieurs mois déjà
nous sommes prêts et vous savez monsieur
le ministre à travailler avec le
gouvernement et à formuler des
propositions innovantes sur le sujet
mais la perspective de cette loi
logement ne doit pas nous conduire pour
autant à repousser d'un revers de la
main toute adaptation du cadre fiscal
dès ce PLF l'article 6 de ce projet
comme d'ailleurs certains amendements du
Gouvernement montre bien que vous nous
rejoignz dans la nécessité d'agir dès à
présent même si nous si nous pouvons
avoir ici et là quelques divergence
d'appréciation vous avez avec l'article
6 décidé de revoir le périmètre du pré
àau zéro qui est un bon outil pour
soutenir une politique d'accession à la
propriété la question des zones tendues
est la plus urgente certes cependant
nous nous pensons que ces réformes de
ces dernières années pour être encore
plus efficace en reforçant l'accès au
PTZ en effet pour dynamiser l'accession
à la propriété des ménages à revenus
modestes et intermédiaire notamment dans
les centres-villees à à revitaliser et
les territoires ruraux nous proposons
des ajustements quant au age du
dispositif du prêt à taux zéro souhaité
par le gouvernement pour qu'un plus
grand nombre de ménages y soit éligible
et pour renforcer son efficacité face à
la hausse des taux nous souhaitons
relever le montant de la prise en charge
ainsi que les plafonds de ressources il
faut également soutenir partout sur le
territoire les opérations de
déconstruction reconstruction pour
adresser une réponse systémique et
efficace sur le long terme à la pénurie
de logement nous en appelons à une
réforme structurelle de la fiscalité des
plus-values immobilières qui pourrait
dans une première étape porter sur les
terrains à bâtir l'abattement pour durée
de détention encourageant le phénomène
de rétention foncière doit selon nous
être supprimé en imposant les
plus-values à la flat taxe tout en
indexant sur l'inflation par ailleurs
cette traréfaction de l'offre de
logement permanent notamment en zone
touristique étendu est accentué par un
phénomène qui a pris de l'ampleur ces
dernières années la prolifération de
location de courte durée sur les
plateformes de location en ligne ce
phénomène augmente les prix et réduit le
nombre de logements disponibles pour les
résidents permanents entraînant des
déséquilibres important sur les
territoires pour mieux en comprendre les
causes nous échangeons depuis plusieurs
mois avec les acteurs des territoires
concernés et les professionnels du
tourisme un point fait consensus la
réponse doit être fiscale face à des
effets d'obè trop importants mais elle
ne doit pas se tromper de cible et être
global ceux qui prétendent résoudre la
crise du logement dans les territoires
touristiques en s'attaquant uniquement à
la fiscalité des meublés classés de
tourisme se trompe puisque ceci ne
représente que 10 à 15 % des logements
présents sur les plateformes de location
en ligne autrement dit toucher seulement
la fiscalité des meublés classés c'est
s'attaquer à un petit bout du problème
sans adresser l'essentiel et c'est
envoyer un mauvais signal aux acteurs du
tourisme et aux quelques 450 stations
classées de tourisme dont 250 sont en
zone tendue ainsi qu'au 1204 communes
touristiques je ne citerai que quelques
exemples de stations touristiques en
zone tendue les ches la clusa exlbin
chartre aubernaet Berk Cabour La
Rochelle les Sables d'Olonne Bordeaux
anglette la grande mote canne carry
rouet ou Balar clbain quel message
enverrons-nous aux propriétaires
vertueux qui ont fait le choix de
classer leur meublés et aux stations qui
souhaitent préserver les 70 %
d'hébergement classés indispensable à à
l'obtention de leur classement station
de tourisme d'où découlent vous le savez
certains avantages pour maintenir
l'activité touristique au cœur de nos
territoires tout en y maintenant une
offre de logement pour les habitants à
l'année nous avons travaillé de concert
avec nos partenaires du Groupe horizon
pour développer une réponse appropriée
et d'ensemble elle entend distinguer la
fiscalité de la location de courte durée
faisant faisant l'objet de facturation
et celle de longue durée faisant l'objet
de beau elle entend faire converger la
fiscalité de la location de logements
nus et celle de courte durée et
préserver nos meublés classés de
tourisme tout en proposant une refondte
plus exigeante de leurs critères mes
chers collègues vous l'aurez compris le
groupe démocrate est déterminé dans le
cadre de ce PLF et dans les mois à venir
à apporter des réponses efficaces pour
sortir de la crise du logement que nous
traversons comme notre majorité le fait
depuis 6 ans soutenons une politique de
l'offre relançons la construction
bâtissons ensemble comme nous savons le
faire une solution efficiente je vous
remercie je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
François joliver pour le groupe
horizon merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues alors le temps du logement
monsieur le ministre c'est un temps long
qui franchit les étapes électorales
facilement et souvent ceux qui en vivent
les conséquen n'ont pas eu à voter pour
ceux qui avaient décidé parce qu'en fait
le temps du logement est un temps
tellement long que ceux qui décident ne
voient jamais la conséquence de leur
décision alors on peut avoir des écarts
sur ces bans sur la notion de crise
nationale du logement nous groupe
horizon et apparenté nous croyons plus à
des crises territoriales de l'habitat et
à des crises résidentielles ou plutôt
des aussi à des crises du parcours
résidentiel de l'habitant la
problématique sans doute de Paris n'est
pas celle de la métropole de Bordeaux
n'est pas celle de Hoche n'est pas celle
de Poitier et pas plus celle de
châurou vous dire aussi
que on peut au moins partager en
revanche un diagnostic commun et lors de
la mission des finances grâce à l'action
et de son président et du rapporteur
général un diagnostic partagé a été mené
nous faisons tous le constat que la
filière immobilière est en train de
s'arrêter si je devais prendre une image
je dirit que c'est un pquebo un super
tanker qui se met en travers d'une île
et qu'il faudra faire
repartir cela avoir d'abord des
conséquences budgétaires monsieur le
ministre
immédiate tout le monde s'accorde dans
les parmi les experts pour dire que il
manquerait 100000 logements entre 100000
et 120000 logements construits le prix
moyen en 2022 d'un logement était de
€. Hors Taxe multiplié par 20 %
multiplié par 100000 ça fait 4 milliards
de recettes en mois vous dire aussi que
la filière immobilière ça va du
notaire jusqu'au notaire du terrain
jusqu'à la vente en mettant à
l'intérieur bien entendu les acteurs du
logement que l'on appelle les promoteurs
mon attachement moi n'est pas forcément
pour le métier de promoteur ou pour ce
qu' le représente mais je considère que
ce sont des acteurs indispensables à la
production parce que je n'oublie pas que
je suis le rapporteur du budget du
logement et de l'hébergement et que ce
sont eux qui produisent 54 % des
logements sociaux ce qui veut donc dire
que il manquera vraisemblablement 54 %
des logements sociaux l'année prochaine
que nous envisageons et ce ne sont pas
les efforts que vous avez demandé à une
structure placée sous le contrôle du
Parlement que l'on appelle la Caisse des
dépôts à une autre qui s'appelle Action
Logement qui est donc issue du
paritarisme que nous pourrons sauver
tous les programmes des promoteurs menés
puisque que ils doivent les acheteurs
doivent respecter leur modèle économique
et heureusement alors le groupe
apparenté Horizon a quelques idées
d'abord vous dire que nous ne croyons
pas et ma collègue Marina Ferrari l'a
dit nous ne croyons pas l'alignement de
la fiscalité des meublés avec
les hébergements des stations
touristiques puisqueen fait nous loupons
ou nous avons le sentiment de louper
notre cible et en fait il faut dis comme
elle l'a très bien dit les logements
facturés de court terme et les logements
qui font l'objet de beau et je crains
d'ailleurs que ceux qui font l'objet de
qui sont qualifiés d'hébergement de
tourisme ceux qui sont amenés à avoir
des audits tous les 3 ans 4 ans pour
faire en sorte qu'ils conservent leurs
étoiles et bien je crains que il les
sortent du dispositif et et qu'il soit
encore un marché supplémentaire pour les
plateformes de
en ligne et je crois que nous loupons la
cible et nous y sommes défavorables et
fortement défavorables vous dire aussi
que pour sauver les acteurs de la
promotion immobilière parce qu'il
construit 54 % de la production de
logement social nous avons imaginé faire
comme ça avait été fait en
1993 et bien monsieur Baladur avait
imaginé ça avait été voté à l'unanimité
de sortir l'ensemble des biens des
droits de succession qui étai achetés
dans les 6 mois à la date de la
publication de la finance donc au 1er
janvier d'ailleurs cette amendement
présenté en commission a
failli gagner son combat ensuite nous
souhaitons également que le PTZ soit
ouvert sur l'ensemble des territoires et
ce pendant une période de 18 mois
d'ailleurs je trouve je trouve
extrêmement anormal et je sais que vous
allez réviser la copie que les mesures
qui ont passé les 154 communes en plus
dans vers la zone B1 et bien elles ont
ça a eu pour conséquence d'écarter ceux
qui avaient un dossier de financement
pour un logement pour un logement en
zone B2 et en zone B2 ben on ne peut
acheter que des anciens et je vais
fininir madame la Présidente en vous
disant que dans le même esprit je pense
qu'il faut que nous arrivions à
retrouver une rentabilité à la
production de logement parce que sans
cela le secteur privé ne sera pas au
rendez-vous et les
continueront à attendre des logements je
vous remercie de votre
attention la parole est à Monsieur taté
le gayic pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et
[Applaudissements]
républicaine
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
commission des finances mon le
rapporteur général
au 25 ou 26 valeureux collègues présents
encore ce soir ainsi qu'au valeureux
fonctionnaires de l'Assemblée
yauran comme l'a rappelé mon collègue
Jean-Marc Tellier notre groupe porte le
projet d'une fiscalité plus juste qui
répartit de manière équitable les outils
de création de richesse ainsi que la
richesse produite ces mesures d'équité
sont nécessaires notamment dans nos pays
dit
d'outrem car nos économies sont
structurellement détenus par des
monopoles qu'on peut compter sur les
doigts de la main monopole implantés
initialement et maintenu par
l'administration
coloniale permettez-moi d'apporter un
éclairage au regard de l'impact de votre
politique budgétaire dans les pays dit
d'outre mè concernant la
défiscalisation les dispositifs d'aide
fiscale à investissement productif en
outrem bien qu'imparfait sont des outils
qui favorisent la création de richesse
dans nos pays respectifs il est ainsi
important de péréniser ces dispositifs
et nous sommes étonnés de l'amendement
de dernière minute déposé par le
rapporteur général qui vise à réduire le
champ d'application la
défiscalisation nous dénonçons la
méthode d'utiliser de nous imposer un
amendement sans dialogue avec les
principaux intéressés c'est-à-dire les
députés d'outrem nous demandons au
gouvernement de ne pas intégrer cet AM
dans le 493 qui sera déposé et cette
demande sera matérialisée par un
courrier Cigné par une majorité des
députés des pays d'outrem qui sera remis
au ministre Vigier demain
matin si vous souhaitez faire des
économies c'est la première fois
peut-être que je vais vous proposer de
faire des économies nous vous proposons
de retirer le pays de mainoui actuel
Polynésie du décret numéro 96-000 2028
relatif à l'attribution à l'attribution
de l'indemnité d'éloignement au
magistrat et au fonctionnaires
titulaires et stagiaires de l'État en
service dans notre pays la raison est
que cette indemnité d'éloignement
attribué aux uniques fonctionnaires de
l'État français considéré comme expatrié
dans nos pays est obsolète et créer un
effet d'è il est préférable de soutenir
la formation et le retour des
originaires dans nos pays respectifs
pour investir dans une main d'œuvre de
qualité qui connaît son pays et qui
investit réellement dans son
pays concernant les conventions fiscales
état
pays cell passés avec nos pays océaniens
encore français sont obsoletes inégales
et très défavorables à nos pays
respectifs il est nécessaire qu'un
dialogue je m'adresse au ministre
s'installe entre l'État et les
gouvernements de mainoui et de kanaki
afin d'établir une véritable convention
fiscal entre l'État et chacun de ces
deux
pays un point spécifique à mainoui la
convention fiscale étatp toujours en
vigueur signée en 1957 en pleine période
d'installation imposée du centre
d'expérimentation du Pacifique ne tient
pas compte des évolutions fiscales
actuelles notre économie pr CEP avant
1957 avait une balance commerciale
excédentaire
elle a été complètement détruite pour
réinstaller une économie de comptoir
extrêmement dépendante du nucléaire
jusqu'en 1996 à son jet 70 % de
l'économie polynésienne dépendait du
nucléaire pour compenser le
démantelllement du CEP en 1996 l'État a
créé une dotation dite d'autonomie
versée annuellement au pays maori à
hauteur de 151 millions d'euros soit 18
milliards de francs cette dotation n'a
pas été augmentée depuis 27 ans malgré
l'inflation à minima nous demandons à ce
que cette
dotation soit indexée en fonction de
l'inflation car les coût supporté par
cette dotation ont eux bien suivi
l'inflation par ailleurs la suppression
de la CVAE et l'absence de présentation
d'un dispositif de
compensation convaincant inquiète les
collectivités territoriales d' d'outr
mère qui ont bénéficie et qui créent de
voir leur budget de fonctionnement
réduit or ce budget de fonctionnement
est déjà sous-doté puisque la DGF versé
à certaines collectivités territoriales
dit d'outreemè est calculé sur la base
d'un recensement qui sous-estime le
nombre d'habitants dans nos pays
particulièrement en Guyane et à Mayotte
car la DGF est calculée tous les 6 7 ans
alors nous proposons de maintenir cette
CVAE telle qu'elle existait en
2020 de plus le gouvernement français
souhaite financer la filière train par
une taxation des compagnies aériennes
cela impacterait directement le passager
sur le principe favoriser le train
plutôt que l'avion est nécessaire d'un
point de vue écologique mais pour les
pays d' d'outrem l'avion n'est pas une
option finalement le gouvernement
français propose de taxer les aéroports
ce subtil tour de passe mènera de toute
manière au même résultat puisque les
sociétés aéroportuaires augmenteront
leurs redevances aux compagnies
aériennes qui
elles répercuteront sur le billet
d'avion la non exonération des pays
d'outr-emè de cette taxation
supplémentaire serait une fois encore la
manifestation d'un manque de
considération de nos réalités en
conclusion comme vous le constatez nos
réalités ne sont pas celles de
l'Hexagone et l'application de votre
politique budgétaire ne peut-être
homogène et unilatérale il est
nécessaire qu'un dialogue se construit
entre le gouvernement et les députés des
pays
d'outreem pour que cet argent soit bien
utilisé dans nos territoires Mar marorou
madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues il est
minuit je vous propose tout de même de
terminer la discussion générale nous
avons deux inscrits après il y aura la
prise de parole de monsieur le Président
de la commission puis monsieur le
ministre euh la parole est à Madame
Goulet pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
cette première partie du proj de
finances pour 2024 arrive à un moment où
nous devons faire nation où nous devons
faire preuve de responsabilité et où de
nombreux français demandent une plus
grande équité fiscale et sociale en
pratique nous saluons le plan de lutte
contre la fraude qui est nécessaire pour
renforcer le civisme fiscal afin
d'assurer la solidité de notre contrat
social et la bonne santé de nos finances
publiques les nouveaux outils juridiques
présents dans ce texte doivent permettre
à l'administration fiscale de mieux
détecter et sanctionner les fraudeurs
mieux les détecter en en adaptant le
cadre juridique aux enjeux du numérique
et mieux les sanctionner en créant d'une
part un régime de sanction gradué
applicable à l'ensemble des fraudes aux
aides publiques et d'autre part un
nouveau délit de mise à disposition
d'instruments de facilitation de fraude
fiscale lutter contre la fraude fiscale
c'est aussi lutter contre le dumping
social la transposition de l'accord de
l'OCDE visant à assurer un niveau
minimum d'imposition mondiale à 15 %
pour les grandes sociétés est une
victoire c'est un gage d'équité pour les
entreprises de notre pays car mes chers
collègues n'oublions pas que ce sont les
entreprises qui font la dynamique
économique de notre pays et qui
garantisent notre modèle social gardelon
bien à l'esprit d'ailleurs cette avancée
doit je crois en aspirer d'autres
simultanément à l'échelle nationale et
européenne convaincu qu'il faut
distinguer dans la fiscalité les
bénéfices utiles des bénéfices futiles
nous croyons fermement que la taxation
des programmes de rachat d'action doit
trouver sa place dans le texte final
afin d'encourager les entreprises à
investir plus et à moins distribuer pour
faire face notamment au grands défis
environnementaux de notre
temps ce texte s'attache aussi à des
vecteurs de justice sociale notamment en
prorogeant de de années le crédit
d'impôt octroyé pour l'adaptation des
logements en cas de perte d'autonomie
cette prise en compte du handicap mais
aussi de l'âge et de la perte
d'autonomie répond à un besoin de notre
société notre attention au groupe
démocrate porte aussi sur celles et ceux
qui travaillent ces familles toujours à
la limite celles qui gagnent un peu trop
pour bénéficier des aides mais pas assez
pour assz pour assurer une sérénité du
quotidien c'est aussi pour eux que nous
travaillons c'est pour eux que nous
portons une position d'équilibre c'est
cet état social protecteur que nous
mettons en œuvre n'oublions pas que près
de 50 % de la dépense publique se
consacre aux prestations sociale c'est
un appui de l'État à l'ensemble de ses
citoyens le groupe démocrate est est
attaché à l'idée que la fiscalité doit
être équitable et
solidaire tout d'abord en matière de
justice fiscale nous souhaitons rendre
l'imposition plus équilibré entre les
revenus du capital et les revenus du
travail et nous souhaitons recentrer les
efforts financiers consentis vers les
classes moyennes un impôt plus juste
plus équitable tout en assurant une
stabilité économique de nos recettes
fiscales c'est ce que nous avons proposé
dans nos indexations des deux des deux
premières tranches et pas des suivantes
ensuite des dispositifs existants ont
montré leurs preuves et nous voulons les
renforcer à l'heure où nous venons de
voter le texte pour le plein emploi avec
un volet nécessaire sur la garde des
enfants de moins de 3 ans nous devons
également permettre aux parents d'enfant
de primaire de pouvoir concilier vie de
famille et vie professionnelle c'est
ainsi que nous pensons nécessaire que le
crédit d'impôt pour les frais de garde
d'enfants hors de domicile actuellement
possible jusqu'au 6 ans de l'enfant soit
étendu jusqu'au 11 ans des enfants soit
l'âge de rentrer au collège l'âge où ils
acquèrent un peu plus d'autonomie
ensuite les parents de d'enfants
situation de handicap ont toujours peur
du jour où ils ne seront plus là pour
les accompagner actuellement une rende
survie peut-être souscrite au bénéfice
d'un enfant mineur handicapé nous
proposons d'étendre cette possibilité
aux majeurs car lorsque le handicap
intervient à Laprès la majorité il doit
être possible pour des parents de
souscrire ce type d'assurance pour
assurer l'avenir de leurs enfants c'est
une injustice que nous souhaitons
réparer enfin dans le contexte
d'inflation que nous vivons nous devons
entendre les inquiétudes des
associations d'aide alimentaire c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons une
prolongation du dispositif Coluche à
1000 € afin de permettre aux
associations de pérenniser les donations
per
pérenniser ce dispositif c'est permettre
de répondre aux demandes qui augmentent
de nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles alors mes chers collègues si le
groupe démocrate souhaite renforcer ce
projet Jois de finance pour 2024 c'est
pour faire progresser la justice fiscale
et la justice sociale dans notre pays je
vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas du
ponignon
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général dans l'histoire
économique et budgétaire de notre pays
nous avons connu des gouvernement qui
mettaiit en œuvre de grandes réformes
sociales mais qui étaient de très
mauvais gestionnaires à l'inverse nous
avons connu d'autres majorités qui
savaient gérer avec précaution les
comptes de la nation mais qui ont laissé
s'aggraver la fracture sociale
malheureusement avec vous nous avons la
double peine une politique budgétaire
qui nous conduit à la faillite une
politique budgétaire profondément
injuste depuis 2017 la dette de la
France accru de 800 milliards d'euros un
record notre dette dépasse les 3000
milliards d'euros Emmanuel Macron qui
avait été présenté comme le Mozart de la
finance l'homme de la compétence a a été
en définitive le champion toute
catégorie confondu de l'endettement
public des déficits budgétaires et
commerciaux malheureusement ce projet de
loi 2024 va encore aggraver la situation
avec une hypothèse de croissance de 1,4
% largement supérieure aux prévisions de
la Banque de France une prévision de
l'inflation de 2,6 % qui ne tient pas
compte de l'augmentation du prix du
pétrole les recettes sont surestimé les
dépenses sont sous-estimées même le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques tire la
sonnette d'alarme quant à la viabilité
j'allais dire la sincérité de ce budget
qui ne trompe plus personne comme vous
êtes incapable de faire une vraie chasse
au gaspillage public et j'y reviendrai
dans un instant comme vous êtes
incapable de taxer les super profits des
oligarques dont vous êtes en fin de
compte les marionnettes vous n'avez
évidemment alors aucune marge de
manœuvre œvre pour prendre les vraies
mesures sociales qui s'imposent pour les
Français qui avec le retour de
l'inflation n'ont jamais autant souffert
vous refusez de mettre en œuvre une Rist
tourde élémentaire sur les carburants
vous réduisez le bouclier tarifaire faut
d'ailleurs d'oser sortir du marché
européen de l'électricité qui
permettrait de traiter à la racine le
problème vous refusez de revenir sur
votre acharnement depuis 2017 à détruire
le secteur du logement tous les
avantages tâch financier dont il
bénéficiait ont été rabotés diminution
de crédit réduction d'APL taxation des
bailleurs sociaux suppression de
l'avantage fiscal Pinel en un mot vous
êtes les premiers responsables de la
crise du logement qui frappe durement
nos concitoyens les Français ne sont
plus dupes de vos choix budgétaires
Diges du shérif de Nottingham dans Robin
des Bois pill les pauvres pour enrichir
ceux qui accumulent toujours plus mais
plutôt que d'ajouter des critiques nos
concitoyens attendent de la part des
oppositions une alternative budgétaire
un vrai budget concilion bonne gestion
préparation de l'avenir et réduction des
inégalités sociales passe au préalable
et vous le savez parce que vous n'osez
pas le faire la par la chasse au
gaspillage les 20 milliards d'économies
que permettraiit une vraie chasse aux
millions de fauses cartes vitales de
faux numéros d'immatriculation de
sécurité sociale les 5 à 10000 milliard
d'euros que permettrait la fin de la
submersion migratoire les 10 à 12
milliards nets que nous donnons à
l'Union européenne pour financer les
concurrents de notre agriculture et de
notre industrie et comble de tout record
d'un compétences le surcût de 12
milliards d'euros mis au budget 2022
pour payer les emprunts à taux variable
indexé sur l'inflation un emprunt à taux
variable que vous continuez à à faire
chaque mois alors que vous savez que
emprunter sur l'inflation coûtera
beaucoup plus cher au contribuable
demain qu'emprunter à tau fixe ces
économies permettraient à l'état de
retrouver la marge de manœuvre
financière pouvant alors est utilisé
selon les choix politiques de chacun
pour relever les principaux défis du
pays j'en vois pour ma part trois le
défi du pouvoir d'achat qui passe par
des mesures sociales concrètes la
suppression de la TVA sur la taxe
intérieure sur les produits pétroliers
une TVA à taux zéro sur des produits de
première nécessité une incitation une
récompense du travail une politique
familiale une politique du logement le
défi deuxièmement euh de la
relocalisation industrielle qui passe
par des avantages fiscaux ciblés comme
l'ont fait d'ailleurs les États-Unis à
un moment sur les PME qui investissent
et augmentent leur production sur le
territoire national enfin le défi de la
reconstruction de nos services publics
de l'hôpital aux universités en passant
par l'école qui ont besoin de moyens
financiers supplémentaires pour offrir
des salaires attractifs à nos policiers
gendarmes infirmiers enseignants enfin
malheureusement au mépris de notre
démocratie vous avez déjà annoncé
l'usage du 493 pour surtout éviter tout
débat parlementaire qui par le biais des
amendements montrerait aux Français
qu'il y a une autre politique budgétaire
possible
ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 je vais appeler les article du
projet de loi et la parole est à madame
la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre s'il vous plaît la parole est à
madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président de la commission des
finances
mon si vous connaissez la procédure vous
savez que c'est la parole est à madame
la Première ministre et que vous n'avez
pas la parole donc je vous remercie de
vous taire monsieur Boyard madame la
Première ministre madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés le projet Doig de Finance est un
texte
fondamental c'est la clé de voûte de nos
politiques publiques c'est la réponse
aux préoccupations des Françaises et des
Français ce sont des moyens pour le
pouvoir d'achat pour le plein emploi
pour la transition écologique pour nos
services publics et pour l'ordre
républicain sur tous ces points ce
budget présente des avancées majeures
c'est un budget pour nos armées pour
notre sécurité intérieure pour notre
justice auquel nous des moyens inédits
des moyens dont le contexte actuel nous
rappellent combien ils sont nécessaires
combien nous en avons besoin pour
protéger les Français c'est un budget
vert il permet d'accélérer la transition
écologique en y consacrant des moyens
sans précédent 41 milliards d'euros
l'année prochaine c'est 7 milliards
d'euros de plus que cette année c'est un
budget pour notre école avec une
revalorisation historique de nos
enseignants
une augmentation de 125 € minimum par
mois j'ajoute que c'est un budget de
cohérence il maintient le cap de notre
politique économique et met en acte
notre engagement pas de hausse d'impôt
nous continuons même à diminuer les
impôts de production avec une nouvelle
baisse d'un milliard d'euros notre
objectif est inchangé supprimer
totalement la CVAE d'ici la fin du
quinquena c'est enfin un budget de
responsabilité il respecte notre
trajectoire de réduction des déficits
publics avec 16 milliards d'euros
d'économie l'an prochain mesdames et
messieurs les députés pour ce budget
comme pour les précédents nous avons
tendu la main et chercher des points
d'accord nous avons discuté
[Applaudissements]
a nous avons discuter avec tous les
groupes
nous avons discuté avec tous les groupes
notamment dans le cadre des dialogues de
Bery nous avons enfin accepté de faire
évoluer notre texte en reprenant des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions je pense à l'assouplissement
des conditions d'accès au pré àau zéro
qui sera désormais ouvert à 6 millions
de Français je pense à l'abattement
exceptionnel pour les plus-values
foncières pour libérer des terrains à
bâtir je pense à la lutte contre la
fraude ou encore au renforcement des
dispositifs d'aide au carburant pour les
travailleurs cependant aujourd'hui le
constat est clair aucun groupe
d'opposition n'est prêt à voter ce
projet de loi de finance
or or notre
pays or notre pays a besoin de ce budget
nous avons besoin de cette première
partie du PLF pour financer nos projets
et les et les réponses aux défis
auxquels nous faisons
face s'il vous
plaît alors ça n'a rien de drôle je vous
demande de respecter madame la Première
ministre le respect c'est un minimum
dans cette je sais pas si vous prenez
modèle monsieur le député sur l'autre
bord de l'hémicycle ça fait assez peu
progresser le
[Applaudissements]
débat
allez un peu de silence vous laissez
madame la Première ministre s'exprimer
madame la Première ministre de part et
d'autre comme à chaque fois comme à
chaque fois que ce que ce sera
nécessaire j'agirai en conscience et
dans l'intérêt du pays et des
Français aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2024 je
vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
première
ministre l'Assemblée nationale prend
acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
le texte
sur madame la Première ministre
messieurs les ministres messieurs les
ministres messieurs les ministres je
n'ai pas fini la séance elle n'est pas
levée je vous
remercie
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de
la présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 16h59 et voté dans
les conditions prévues à l'article 49 de
la Constitution dans l'hypothèse où une
motion de censure serait dép
la Conférence des Présidents fixera la
date et les modalités de sa discussion
la séance est
suspendue